there's no time
[Music]
13 o clock hey y'all it's episode 166
yeah what's this this is about Vampire
Killers Vampire Killers vampire
assaulters fam you have like a whole
bunch of different cases on this one and
as you can see I'm in a new [ __ ] chair
this is a [ __ ] throne [ __ ] with me
about sitting in that ready ass chair
and when that alcohol had a good grip on
me when the spirit of kukulcan overtook
me like it does when I'm drinking
tequila
I'll start shifting around in that chair
too much because it's not all that
comfortable so I said [ __ ] it I'm gonna
go straight up Merv Griffin Show I'm
gonna sit up in this [ __ ] like
the most interesting man yeah world like
I said you need a cigar yeah an innocent
a damn suit jacket or coat yeah do you
have one you have one yeah 30 for them
you should put that on I open at home
you need like a really loud checkered
one like Merv Griffin so you can like
pretend in 70s oh yeah have like a
little snifter of brandy and big old
[ __ ] cigar like the round we got we
got Dennis with us Dennis is in position
he is yeah look at him there
Dennis is in position tearing into your
souls but yeah so this show like I said
since it's October we're doing kind of
variety shows several cases on one
episode and since it's almost Halloween
next week is gonna be our Halloween
episode um I decided to do vampire
killers especially because we had been
talking about doing rod Ferrell for a
while and we've also had Richard Trenton
chase has been requested a bunch of
times
read a whole book on chase a long time
ago yes I was in Egypt on the MFO Miss
I read a book about chase yeah yeah
we'll probably save him till last yeah
and I worked for one of Farrell's
lawyers his first lawyer yeah remember
Candice yeah yeah I saw his I saw his
Case Files but she didn't handle his
trial just his original arrest when you
got extradited back here to Florida yeah
a little wild and then passed him on to
another lawyer later on yeah I was
watching a documentary with about him
today and it's like I forgot what a
douche that guy I mean clearly but I
mean you know what I mean like when they
interview him it's just like he's
troubled
that's a very diplomatic yeah sure we'll
talk about him winning it will be good
there was more to him than meets the eye
in terms of just I kind of know where
he's coming from you know we know the
time the 90 yeah and we know the scene
that he was coming out of you know what
the goth scene I was gonna talk about
that a little bit you it's yeah it's
like it's not marching him that I but
you know the other people like his
friends that knew him at the time like
before he killed people um I can
understand where they were coming from
for sure like growing up in some
horrible town in Kentucky where so you
know I feel that he just went too far
yeah obviously lost his mind went too
far but we're going to we're going to go
too far ahead yeah
yeah but yeah so what I did like I said
this will be the two kind of main
attraction sort of vampire killers and
then I also found like a handful of
other kind of not as involved cases
about either killers or people who
committed crimes that were
vampire-related not gonna do the Atlas
vampire cuz we already put her on the or
we already put that person on our Sweden
show yeah it did like a murder in Sweden
show that so we're gonna leave that one
off but these ones these ones are all
pretty fun so all right when I say
episode 166 what are our shout outs on
this one I don't remember I know
somebody somebody thinks that they have
a computer for us that's right yeah yeah
we'll see how that goes I'm very excited
about it
very excited also we got a PayPal
donation from Sandra or Sandra I'm not
sure which way you pronounce it she
comments on our YouTube videos all the
time also probably if you want to send
in a scary story for Halloween you
should probably do it like in the next
day or two
because I'm running out of time and it's
like I'm gonna start putting together
all the stories and whatnot so if you
want one you want one in there then send
it to me at great pic at gmail.com I'll
also put that down in the description
also the audiobook for the associated
villainies my fiction compilation the
first edition of which came out in 2011
I did the second edition and the
audiobook is finally up it took them
like a month yeah it's never taken them
that long before yeah um I but like I
said I guess they just got backed up or
whatever inaudible but it is available
now so go and check it out if your
because I think this is the first
fiction book that I have done an
audiobook I'm gonna get around to doing
all of them eventually but you know they
take a long time to do but this one is
actually up and my other short story
thing hopeful monsters that'll be the
next one to do because I redid the print
and the e-book I'm just still working on
that it's awesome I think well I hope so
yeah cuz you know in case people are
curious about my horror fiction and not
just my true crime self um I think
that's probably it right yeah yeah
alright so I thought probably what we're
gonna do because I have like six tumor
cases and like I said rod Ferrell and
Richard Trenton chase are the big ones
the other ones are kind of shorter so
I'll probably just do like the three or
four short ones first and then we'll
take a break in the talked about the
other two cases yeah cuz I'm I'll be
done with this by this drink by halfway
through it I want this new usually are
I'm on this yeah this is a new drink a
new chair a new drink you all drank
everything I learned this drink in Tampa
that's right yeah at the absolutely we
went to the big city
what are a little rube absolutely that's
that tropical redbull with
the yellowcake Hornitos reposado tequila
and they could you can also use salsa
yeah that's right that's just they were
user than at the bar and a shot of lime
juice that [ __ ] is good we went to the
grocery store to go look for that
tropical Red Bull we were pissed cuz it
looked like they didn't have it but then
there was right there it's just the
yellow one yeah you know look it's in
the fine print it says it's the tropical
one I didn't realize they had so many
different flavors yeah well if I
wouldn't realize that because I can't
stand red ball yeah you're not hip to
Red Bulls game I like I like the energy
drink oh man it tastes like [ __ ]
sweet tarts mixed with Satan's Satan's
taint no gross and it's not and she he's
so funny because he's like he mixes this
drink he knows that I like neither
tequila nor Red Bull I give it to and
yet he still makes me dry
and I'm just like oh it's gross what a
surprise quiet
taste a lot of things are yeah [ __ ]
right it is okay
it's a testosterone thing I think it's
just I noticed that we don't when I'm
[ __ ] lift in and mighty count gets
higher all of a sudden the tequila
tastes better so did the Red Bull soda
[ __ ] sweet tarts all starts tasted
better so there's there's that
testosterone way yeah but maybe
everything tastes better so it's just
kind of like you know a rising tide
lifts all boats congratulations no no
you reading into but you read too much
into it I just made my stage that's what
I do man did the tequila taste it better
okay
the sweet tarts tasted better I don't
like any kind of it I don't really like
energy drinks I don't mind the caffeine
ones like cuz don't don't they do like
the like of all like that monster low
carb coco loco or whatever like that
monster low carb black one with the
light blue M yeah huge yeah I like that
one
you can't drink too many of those a day
though you'll [ __ ] heart your heart
will explode I think it's just a soft
drink I don't I'm not buying into the
hype well there's no well there's a lot
of caffeine in them yeah but there's a
caffeine and a lot of soft drinks well
yeah but I mean some people drink like a
shit-ton I think is the same [ __ ] back
when I was a kid you know hanging out
7-eleven in the 80
they came out of this [ __ ] called Jolt
Cola remember they remember don't call
it said twice the sugar twice the
caffeine nectar like [ __ ] it
yeah like [ __ ] you you know I mean there
you definitely marking and marketing it
to teenage kids you know teenage guys we
go yeah that's good I think that's all
it is something like jolt and I didn't
even taste that different no taste it
exactly the first I'm not a big so they
said like RC yeah it did yeah I can't
even honestly if you gave me like a
blind taste test between Coke Pepsi ours
I probably couldn't tell the difference
could tell RC RC is sweet
Pepsi a sweet - I'm supposed to be but
like ersity was sweeter and it didn't
seem to have as much carbonation it
wasn't quite as carbonated not flat but
it just had a different level of it you
know yeah that's what how I remember it
I haven't seen it in a long time today
but they still make it I think I think
they went out with trailer parks yeah as
trailer parks just started to go away so
did RC Cola well you know they still
make moon pies and [ __ ] and that's
trailer parking the banana Moon Pies
Nana moon fire I don't like it I don't
like banana any artificial yellow yeah
yeah I mean real bananas are tolerable
but anything with that artificial banana
flavor just makes me want to throw up so
bad five seconds in the damn microwave
yeah wrapped yeah I don't know why but I
just I guess cuz you were saying like
about artificial colors and flavors and
stuff but we went to the movies to see
Zombieland double tap and I got the icy
and it's like an Addams Family one and
it's black cherry and it was like black
yeah which I thought was very neat it
actually tasted pretty good too
yeah although you complained about it
because you said well it doesn't like
stop you from being thirsty yeah yeah
it's like like an eight the cup of fluid
just frozen and whipped like eat a snow
you can never satisfy your thirsty
nobody just knows like that but it was
black and it had cherry flavor in it
okay it was good
alright alright so let's start talking
about some
people that think they're vampires and
the [ __ ] that they get up to yeah we
know a couple people that take their
vampires well yeah one in particular so
uh this little case here I just found
this while I was looking you know cuz i
google-searched Vampire Killers to see
what would come up after the Roman
Polanski Fearless Vampire Killers movie
now this is a Florida man story except
it's Florida woman this happened in 2011
this is a very Florida story you guys so
there's this woman named Josephine Smith
at the time she was 22 years old now
this happened in st. Petersburg which is
a little south of Tampa a few couple of
hours from your South of the big city
yeah well it's also a big city talking
[ __ ] yeah you are Lando's now a big city
yeah so this poor 69 year old homeless
man was sleeping outside of a Hooters
restaurant like you do in st. Petersburg
and 22 year old Josephine Smith comes at
it was about midnight so I guess the
Hooters is Hooters open at midnight I
don't know that day it was and she
jumped on top of this poor old homeless
man and says I'm a vampire I'm going to
eat you yeah and then she bit him and
when she all dressed up some sexy [ __ ]
with them oh I don't know
the st. Petersburg Times did not specify
what she was yeah so she jumps on this
guy she bites him on the arm removes the
top layer of skin
she also bit through his lips and he had
to get stitches for that it's probably
like the last thing you feel more maybe
it's not the last thing you're thinking
of when you're homeless sleeping outside
a Hooters that some crazy girl is gonna
jump on you and say there are vampire
and they try to bite your lips off of
course it is a warning
maybe I hope it is yeah okay oh yeah
it's gonna be good out here
is that a [ __ ] hooters chill out yeah
thank you and see he's he's dead he's
that Bob that's constantly in those uh
John Carpenter movies he's that guy
oh yeah it's a guys named pouch that's
where the guy that was the president you
know that were the guy that murdered the
guy that played the bum in dagon like
together yeah yeah or that guy that gave
a he's passed away now but yeah he would
be good too
so yeah so he needed this poor guy
manages to get away from this crazy
woman he goes calls the police he had to
go to the hospital and get his lips
stitched up and stuff like that so she
gets arrested charged with aggravated
battery now when I was like researching
what had happened to her since then it
turns out that she got arrested again in
May of 2015 for stabbing her boyfriend
with a pair of scissors okay this isn't
the same one I was thinking of so well
hmm there's this happen more than once
yeah there's the jumps on an old guy
doesn't show they were a vampire jumped
on this dude and you start attacking
would think she cut his dick off Wow
yeah okay no this is now what I think we
just show about her she killed one guy
remember she was kinda bad we've done so
many horrible things on this show what
they call it big bad woman dress you
know the bbws dressed as a vampire
gothic vampire I think she killed one
guy
she had a whole coven of them female
vampires she's probably about 30 the
rest of them are all in their twenties I
think it was 90s though okay that's
crazy
yeah no this she kind of was like Tara
oh she's kind of like you know that
somebody actually no she's kind when you
look at her she was kinda like Tara if
she's gonna run jumping on do you
actually kill the dude yeah huh well
this yeah this girl didn't didn't kill
the guy
no she didn't now she stabbed her
boyfriend with scissors but he then died
yeah apparently she just they started
having an argument about something or
other and she just decided she wasn't
having any more fish it and she was
working on some sushi was selling some
clothes or something had some scissors
close to him and so yes so they they
have these like um the the mug shots of
her she looks kind of mean in the first
one where she jumps on the homeless guy
but then four years later she was like
all crying and stuff yeah again we she
didn't try to eat him that's the world
that I know of but yeah so that's that
girl now here's another guy that uh this
is a lot less funny this actually
happened in Scotland in 2002 now this
guy's name is Alan Menzies and I love
the way this [ __ ] week I don't love
it but you know what I mean I love the
way this book and article starts and it
just comes in you know this just comes
right in the middle he says a man has
admitted killing his friend drinking his
victims blood and eating part of his
head which part I don't know yeah so
Alan Menzies 22 years old murdered his
21 year old friend Thomas Mackendrick in
Scotland in December of 2002 now
apparently they it was at the friend's
house and I don't know if they got in an
argument or what the [ __ ] happened but
apparently Menzies started hitting his
friend on the head with what they
believe was a baseball bat or some other
like a blunt object similar to that and
then just and then got a knife and just
started like stabbing him like in the
face and everything like that now
apparently he dumps the body into a
drainage ditch where it was found by a
passing police officer like about a
month later I don't know if they were
like searching the area for the guy or
something like that because he was
missing but they see a forearm and a
hand sticking out of his drainage ditch
and they're like oh that looks a little
suspicious I'm gonna go check that out
now they go to Alan Menzies his house
and it turns out that he is like a
really big like an right
fanboy like he's got Queen of the Damned
he's got blood and gold he says oh he's
read like Queen of the Damned like a
hundred times and he's like super super
into it and like they go through the
books and just like in some like shitty
ass horror movie like he's written like
all these notes like in the margins and
stuff I guess when he found like her
particularly you know good passage that
was like oh yeah that's totally what I'm
feeling right you know what I mean it
was like he probably did that it's like
yeah it's like they said it was really
badly spelled but he had written like
stuff like the blood is the life I've
drunk the blood and it shall be mine for
I have seen horror like all this other
kind of crap how the nineties right well
no this was 2002 well I think that's
when that was written yeah yeah it's it
I remember okay
the 90s I have to say are probably my
least favorite decade that I have lived
through I don't know I've seven fun
though see towards the end I did not
like the beginning of them the beginning
was okay but I didn't really I didn't
like you know I just didn't like the
whole I didn't like the way the music
was going I didn't like the way the
fashion was going I just I don't know
there was just something about it I
didn't like I liked it that's you
towards the end yeah yeah I think it
started to get better toward then it's
like and I think I mentioned it before
unlike some of our like retrospective
reviews it's like that's I can count on
probably one or two hands like the good
horror movies that came out the whole
entire decade strawberry switchblade
came out very switchblade came out just
garbage you know they're just yeah there
was good stuff I'm not saying that yeah
I'm just saying that after the 80s it
seemed like kind of a letdown I guess
you know I can dance yeah like I said
it's I'm not saying that wasn't good
[ __ ] there was but I do feel like the
one thing that I didn't like I mean I
feel like I liked in the 80s how yeah
like if you were goth or punk or
whatever and you kind of got [ __ ] on a
picked on cuz nobody knew what the [ __ ]
that was right
but in a way I kind of like that better
that nobody knew what it was after not
the 90s and personally I blame Nirvana
but especially after like grunge got
really popular and like alternative
music got really popular and then you
know all the kids like 13 year olds or
shopping at Hot Topic and it's like
suddenly everybody was and it's just
like it's just I don't know it just
pissed me off my friends back then we
just laughed they would say alternative
music like alternative to what yeah that
was mainstream music it was and it was
like there was no alternative it's just
that it's really weird to explain to
like somebody that wasn't alive during
that time it's like prior to really
nineteen nineteen ninety-one 1992 I mean
there was a very there was a pretty
strident like difference between like
people that rent a [ __ ] we were into and
people that were just in the like
regular [ __ ] I mean nobody they didn't
know what our music they didn't know
like all these kind of like weird cult
movies and it's not it's not like now
we're like everybody knows everything
yet everything no you had to find it
back then yeah because but I mean the
internet wasn't really a thing I mean we
didn't even have the Internet until 94
95 something like that
yeah well as the internet started to
come in in the 90s you know I was doing
some of the very first online shop and I
had damn web TV yeah the idea having a
[ __ ] ATM card and you could buy
something that was blowing my mind that
was like something that you see out of
the movie self was like at a out of our
Ward's negev oh yeah you know Arnold
buys a dam and in what was it Running
Man and he buys a plane ticket over
WebTV yeah on the top on that man I have
that now oh it's like the Jetsons yeah
they didn't hit you couldn't really
stream over the internet but the
internet was starting to become
something useful yeah and you had it if
you didn't have it you didn't have a
computer like I had boat for a while
well I lost and went back and forth
there were times where I didn't have a
PC and I just used web TV and then later
on I got away a PC again you know but it
was just just a weird time you couldn't
stream online you could only like surf
do some research
buy stuff and forums yeah there was like
a like message board forum
and I got caught up in there like the
flame wars of 1998 where every time you
went to a discussion group
you were flaming the [ __ ] out of it this
is like now you know they've been
companies online wars you know recently
there was nothing like the flame the
flame wars Alicia there was even like
one flame in the [ __ ] it was even one of
the earliest like um using it I think it
was one of the earliest Usenet groups
was mst3k fans yeah and holy crap when
the whole Mike the whole Joel Mike thing
happened yeah as a flame war holy [ __ ]
that was like a big [ __ ] deal this
people still talk about that judge yeah
you could fight with people over the
Internet it was [ __ ] like yeah and
then you know you could you could order
stuff from Black Rose or Hot Topic and
it was show up now would blow your
[ __ ] mind and that was that was like
the heyday of Howard Stern I loved
Howard Stern's radio show yeah it was
cutting edge in the day but man adjust
that can't survive against what you have
on the internet now just connectivity is
just a toe it's a whole new ballgame
yeah it's really totally different there
was something about that being new that
the internet was a new thing and you're
starting and it's you could just start
seeing things change
because of the effects yeah of it and
then I saw dude have a laptop and get an
internet internet connection through a
laptop the wireless said that blew my
[ __ ] mind I was like man that's me
she's out of Star Trek never couldn't
even imagine that that must been Ron
maybe like 96 or 97 a food vendor walked
into McDonald's or a restaurant that's
what it was it wasn't it wasn't
McDonald's opened it up and took his
order it was a Cisco guy worked for a
Cisco yeah and took the order that
laptop and I was like well what because
yeah I have a connection like what does
that work it took me yeah I couldn't
process it could [ __ ] process he's
looking he's rolling me rolling his eyes
at me this is that's he's like are you a
hundred years old I'm like the Internet
he's like yeah
but yeah I think honestly that like I
said there was a lot of khals like I
graduated from high school in 1990 so
like you know the 90s were kind of like
my you know college years and [ __ ] like
that but it's like that there was some
good [ __ ] about it but it's like like I
said I really didn't like just the way
the subcultures went particularly
because that's kind of what I you know
what I was really into and that was like
a big part of my life and stuff so I
didn't like the way
like I said everybody suddenly knew
about it and everyone was being like
posers about it but it like really got
on my nerves
yeah when they were the big influx and
new people started showing up yeah a lot
of Manson nights yeah and those which
are ski kids yes because Charles Mann
and that's what's-his-name Marilyn
Marilyn Manson got him in there that's
what I mean it's like they've dad this
big stupid trip pants and it's like
[ __ ] had makeup like the crow and I
just [ __ ] just not yeah how many crows
are in this club nah yeah that used to
be like a joke back then yeah it's like
oh look there's another one
you [ __ ] [ __ ] as a crow you need to
be [ __ ] slab yeah Draven yeah Eric
Draven yeah I mean and I like that movie
it's great movies I'm just saying that
she was just played out by holy [ __ ]
it's like every 13 year old edge Lord
was like out there with that [ __ ]
makeup on there's big [ __ ] gigantic
pants it was ridiculous it was a
ridiculous denying it was a ridiculous
thing and I mean and I was hanging out a
lot of goth clubs back then too and it's
like you see them come in it's like me
and like all the other old peers we
weren't even that old back then we're
just in our early early mid 20s we're
just like looking at I'm just gonna [ __ ]
me look at this [ __ ] here yeah it was
terrible
and it just seemed like a lot of the
music was going in a more like techno e
type of direction yeah and I just ravers
I was and I wasn't there for that I
wasn't there for that much nation though
our diaper [ __ ] I don't like I must give
it to it I must hand it to our
generation though coming up during
during that time people had better
social skills than the kids do today I
don't do the club we Adam
people were throwing down
always been aware it was a sexually
charged environment I was I was in the
good clubs though was it Man Ray in
Boston and I was hanging out at like the
crystal down in in the French Quarter
and stuff later on and also Hellfire
Club you know so yeah it was a sexually
charged scene back in those days
well yeah I remember that a time more so
than it is today I think I think it is
yeah maybe I think it was I don't know
and it was just because I was younger
just people were getting people were up
to yeah you know people were throwing
down back nowadays it's it's it it's
online its online relationships yeah I
did yeah probably in but how do we get
off on this okay we're we're talk about
Anne Rice tombow damn right okay so so
this guy if you love it when we go up
track we get all our fans well I'm like
I said we'll probably end up going back
down that tangent we talk about rod
Ferrell because that was like a lot of
the [ __ ] that I was talking about kind
of relevant to that yeah so this guy
whose huge Anne Rice fan who obviously
related to a lot a lot of the characters
in there decides to kill his friend beat
him to death with a [ __ ] bat or
whatever then he drinks his blood and
eats part of his head and then dumps him
in a drainage ditch and then they
arrested him like a month later after
they found the body they put him in
prison he got eighteen years to life and
he apparently committed suicide in 2004
it was really weird because I looked it
up and they're like yeah he died in
custody in 2004 in our understanding it
was a suicide right like hmm well maybe
even maybe was murdered in prison that's
what I was thinking maybe he got
murdered or maybe one of the what part
of his head he ate I don't know what the
article didn't really say and I'm like
you can't just leave me hanging like
that you know what I mean it's like I'm
not saying that come on you can't just
say ate part of his head I'm like which
part everybody is asking that everybody
all right so this next case
talk about this happened in 2011 in
Massachusetts this guy right here he
went the whole nine yards man he took on
a Latin name from Twilight so all right
partially Caius domitius veo vez no see
that's what I said - it's like
immediately before I even finish reading
that my eyeballs just if you want to let
neighbors just come self Sancho does
they make a lot more sense well I can't
get laid with a name like snog whose you
know my name is Sun show [ __ ] right
man I don't think endeavor that rock
that ok hot so yes Sun show Vasquez yeah
you you look like you you look like a
statue I have to say but yeah so this
guy not only did he have this ridiculous
over-the-top Latin name he also got the
subdermal 's like under his forehead
like two laser swords but they didn't
really look like horns Islam yeah it
just looks like bumps so it's not quite
as cool no I'm like if you're gonna do
horns like go hold or not go horns
they're not cool they're nice well it
doesn't look good like that you just
look like you have a big giant it is
what it looks like yeah so he had that
he had um which I thought was kind of
cool but he had like these bones like
tattooed on his fingers that are green
and stuff but he also has like a bunch
of facial tattoos hmm and it looked like
from the picture it looked like a lot of
them were like kind of runes like across
his face like not in a cool way but it's
just kind of like Anna do she okay I
don't know and also he had 666 tattoo
notice I'm like okay God are you 10 what
the [ __ ] once just stop it it's like no
one is shocked by that anymore
yeah so like I said and this is 2011
this wasn't even back in the 80s when
like people were like it yeah really
much about that one that would have only
made an impact really in the 70s yeah
and even then it's like you know what
like
during the Anton LaVey era right and as
I saw that like when I was walking along
the trail this morning you know behind
our house and we live in like you know a
nice neighborhood and everything but
apparently some kid around here like
decided they were gonna spray-paint a
bunch of [ __ ] and of course they spray
paint on the ground a little bit and
then they spray pin and like when the
stop signs or some [ __ ] and what are
they spray paint six six six I was like
same tired old me no edge it's like yeah
right it's like the kids been doing that
since the [ __ ] yeah Jesus Christ
knock it off put a pentagram on it yeah
and then draw out the wrong door and
they draw out the wrong direction or
they put like a swastika swastika and
they got that [ __ ] yeah it's like no one
is shocked everyone's just like oh it's
probably some [ __ ] kid yeah so yeah
so he's got that on his face he's 34
years old or at least he was in 2011 now
he also says that he's a vampire now
this guy you know as douchey as that
[ __ ] is he did actually kidnap kill and
dismember three men in Massachusetts so
apparently in 2001 they had found the
dismembered bodies of a guy named David
Glasser who was 44 a guy named Edward
Frampton who was 58 and a guy named
Robert Chadwell at who was 47 and they
found them buried inside outside of the
town of Pittsfield Massachusetts they
had all gone missing I think on the same
day or like a right around the same time
they found their bodies about ten days
after they went missing now apparently
this caius vey ovis person yeah that's a
cool name we have to give him a dorky
name what's a dorky latin name Paco's
not Latin like Latin America Latin is in
like Roman lat oh yeah so he apparently
had two henchmen who had normal names
Adam Lee Hall and David chalu Cholewa
something like that and these dudes were
also like old enough to know about
was 37 and was 47 and apparently they
kidnapped these three guys who were like
older dudes I don't know what the [ __ ]
they was going on there so they
kidnapped him and shot them and then cut
them up and like buried them outside of
town
this wasn't drug-related um it might
have been one of the one of the guys
david Glasser was supposed to testify
against Adam Lee Hall who's one of the
guy one of the accomplices yeah and he
was apparently in the Hells Angels yeah
so there might have been some [ __ ] going
on there a drug-related or some kind of
beef he had with the motorcycle gang or
whatever but that said Sancho he said
that he didn't do it or anything like
that but he did actually say that he was
a vampire and like I said he gave
himself that name and everything but he
says that he didn't have anything to do
with these murders even though they
found like all kind of [ __ ] evidence
and even though the other two guys said
he was certainly involved in it but is
it you know I mean it's like he was okay
so he's originally from Maine they said
now he got he changed his name in 2008
his real name is Roy gut Fenske jr.
which I don't blame him I would change
that if I was mine that was my name toi
like Roy
well yeah boy yeah you know you can run
we can roll with that but you could
always just call yourself guff I kind of
like for Guffey Pinsky Pinsky we're
thinking of like a shame Sunnis or black
but yeah so he changed his name now
they're speculating because caius was
the name and I'm a random but apparently
according to the article Caius is a
vampire from the Twilight novels like
the Hulk [ __ ] cools in a 34 year old
man with face tattoos and subdermal horn
implants in his head how cool can you be
if you've named yourself after a vampire
from [ __ ] Twilight you grew up with
that [ __ ] which is like a teen girls og
man he grew up with
saying I mean in a sentimental they got
dudes it's must be just you know they
got some dudes that have some
sentimental qualities you know he saw
that program and just it took him to a
new place took a good new place you know
you're reading Twilight it spoke to him
38 very romantic you know I suppose a
romantic character although like I said
if you're gonna do that it's like at
least like be a little bit classier and
pick something for man right it's like
why don't you call yourself like our
monitors so a lot of a lot of times you
know you guys don't have a bunch of
creativity on their own they don't want
it here too far away from something that
they saw and liked yeah and they're
gonna like stuff that they make they
can't really make anything yeah so yeah
I suppose he thinks he's in Twilight our
vampire friend thinks he's in Twilight
yeah that's really seems to be it's like
if you it's like if you're gonna like
choose to be a vampire and like oh right
on people at least pick cooler ones than
[ __ ] Twilight you on everybody knows
that's lame
Jenny and I knew this guy he was okay he
was in it he was entertaining at first
but as he he's kind of new to the scene
he started buying every bit of clothing
that I had it was super creepy you guys
yeah he was like he was like Thomas
mini-me yeah and then he started going
out with [ __ ] kind of the younger
young girls too and he had he had a
girlfriend who's like a live-in
girlfriend yeah - so he was it's just
weird you know he was trying to be Polly
I guess yeah yeah is what I think was
trying to well it was kind of weird is
that he was a schoolteacher yeah yeah
you wouldn't know by looking at it you
think he was one of students though he
looked like he's about 15 years younger
than he really was yeah cuz he was I was
like surprised when I hold it was cuz he
really does maybe he really is a vampire
yeah cuz he did look like a before get
an 18 year old that [ __ ] fell in love
with me yeah it was what this is like a
weird time in our lives
yes yeah it was very weird is it's all
coming back to haunt all coming back and
I can get rid
well plus the weird thing too is that he
like I said he had like some weird kind
of like fixation or like obsession with
you yeah he kind of wanted to be you
yeah trying to send my den but then like
he was like taking he was taking aspects
of your personality that were not
accurate it was almost kind of like he
was it was like his weird like warped
perception of you yeah and he was acting
like that he took the things he took the
things that impressed he was impressed
by certain aspects of maybe he didn't
understand those aspects right that's a
took him in directions that we're not
what they were yeah
and it was and then he would get mad
that like he would take a photo he'd
like the photo he tried to take that
exact same photo yeah it was really it
was like single white female except yeah
yeah yeah
single white goth dudes when I set that
photo up yeah yeah it it got weird
because I think that he started to well
he started to like manufacture entire
top from try entire beefs and entire
like arguments and stuff that we didn't
even know we're going on yeah like just
because like he read so I was doing
stuff two minutes yeah it's like a light
when I was [ __ ] with him but I was
the [ __ ] winner yeah like was
ignoring him like I said it's like you
would post something on Facebook you
would you know like a picture like or
something and he would think that you
were talking about him even though we
weren't it was like really really weird
yeah and then he would and then like the
next time he came out he'd be like up in
your face like what did you what are you
talking about we weren't even talking
about you or I don't know it was just
very strange I don't know what happened
to him he moved away yeah
but yeah that was it was a very very
weird so apparently even uh before like
he's for this highest person Santo
started getting all his like fabulous
vampire accoutrement he apparently in
1999 him and his girlfriend who was 17
years old at the time
they lured a 16 year old girl to their
motel room they cut open
back with a razor blade and then drank
the blood while they were like making
out with one another so the girl kind of
she got away and then she had to go to
the hospital and cuz they had cut her
back open and she knew like 30 stitches
yeah
so yeah now when now he got arrested for
that like back in 1999 and at the time
he said oh I'm a vampire and a Satanist
and stuff like you always say him and
the girlfriend got convicted of elevated
aggravated assault which I didn't even
know that was thing and in 2000 he got
sentenced to 10 years but then he got
like all but three like he got seven
years suspended like they were so they
let him back out so he was a threat yes
so then after he got out on parole in
2006 he was charged again with
kidnapping and drug possession him and
another guy like were keeping two
strippers in a hotel room and wouldn't
let them leave so then he had to go back
to prison for violating his probation
and then like after that when he got
back out again then he goes and helps
allegedly these other two guys like
murder and cut up three dudes
so keeping two strippers in a hotel room
and not letting him leave that sounds an
awful lot like pimping well yeah some of
that might have been involved also it
was going on there but it was I mean
they charged him with kidnapping
although he he didn't get charged with
that but he did get the drug possession
charge and then he got sent back to
prison because he had violated his
parole like cuz he's up tall like all
other kind of [ __ ]
alright so that guy as far as I know
he's still like saying he's innocent but
he's still in prison he's still like
trying to appeal just have a lot of time
you know I guess all these people all
right so this next case I want to talk
about before we go to break this is the
case of James Riva the schizophrenic
vampire they call him now this guy okay
now this happened in 1980 now what he
did
was I
I mean he had had mental problems you
know since he was young but in the late
70s early 80s he started saying that he
was a 700 year old vampire and that he
either needed to drink blood to live or
that he thought his grandmother who I
believe that he lived with he thought
that she was a vampire and that she was
like sucking out his blood or his life
essence or something like that while he
was sleeping she was clearly like had
some mental issues so in April of 1980
James Riva shoots his 75 pound
grandmother who was in a wheelchair by
the way um he shot her with a gun that
had gold bullets in it how do you manage
that I don't know like I don't know if
he if they were just like gold I think
he just painted them gold so I don't
think they were really gold because that
was that would make sure it kills that
vampire it's like maybe they were
already silver so he had like BAM just
in case just yeah
so he shoes so he shoots his grandmother
in her wheelchair with gold bullets then
he drinks the blood as it's coming out
of the bullet wounds getting to try and
get it back yeah and then he sets her
body on fire and her house on fire
right so yeah so apparently as a kid you
know even when he was like in
kindergarten and [ __ ] like that he was
into you know the same kind of he was
into vampire [ __ ] he was into like
killing animals and all this kind of
stuff he kind of got obsessed with this
idea that his grandmother was a vampire
predator and that while he was sleeping
she would take his blood and that she
was drinking it so he thought that the
only way he could get rid of her and
like get her out of his life was
shooting her with gold bullets for
whatever reason he thought that regular
bullets wouldn't kill her that they had
to be gold bullets but Oh silver kills
event werewolf so gold had to kill you
well silver supposed to kill vampires -
like that that holes will silver ass if
he's going he's taking it one
not above that I guess so right it's
like really scared you use platinum
diamond yes so he was actually this is
another guy who was in a mental
institution he was in there for three
years from 1975 to 1978 and so they knew
something was wrong with him from the
beginning but it's like I guess they
thought that he was okay and like let
him out and then like two years later he
did this kind of [ __ ] but because even
when he was a little kid like they said
he started out like drawing horrible
pictures of like blood everywhere and
[ __ ] like that
then he started killing cats and
beheading cats and the second you start
killing cats or doing anything bad you
can hear yeah I'm just like don't want
anything to do with you anymore I just
want you launched into the Sun so he
started doing that and then he starts
like sneaking into barns and like
drinking blood out of like horses and
cows and stuff hmm you know what I mean
yeah so I don't know so after he killed
his grandmother and they kind of took
him in it was like why did you do it and
stuff and he's like oh I'm 700 years old
I need the blood or she was like
drinking my blood he couldn't really
settle on one story he said that he
thought he was satisfying his masters in
the nether world of vampires
by killing a human being yeah he thought
that if he killed everybody who was bad
to him this is a quote everybody was bad
to him he would come back as a handsome
man and have a car and girls and his
life would be fine okay so how'd that
work out for you James must not have
been good-looking he um I've seen
pictures of him he was a totally normal
and I'm looking yeah perfectly fine
looking gentleman don't you come back
better come back improved they have a
car ride baby carve Oh babes they have a
good haircut oh man now I want to start
a female punk band called car full of
babes yeah I have so many bands I have
to start because I have so many good
names so apparently they put the guy on
trial they found him guilty of
second-degree murder
also of arson
because like I said he said his
grandmother's body in her house on fire
he also in they put him in prison and
then later on he stabbed one of the
guards at the prison hmm but they put
him on trial again for that and they
gave they let him off with it because
reason of insanity which clearly he was
now he is like applied for parole a
bunch of times
yes and they're just like [ __ ] no you
were not going anyplace you are clearly
a crazy person now he comes up before
the parole board in 2009 this was the
second time that he was coming up for
parole and you know they turned him down
now that he said oh you know I've been
going to therapy I don't have like the
resentment thing against my mom anymore
bloody block but then they found out
that he had still been sending like
threatening letters to his mom even as
late as 2009 he was still doing that
[ __ ] so he he would what he said was
that when he was a kid that his mom
would perform quote unquote which
rituals on him and was like trying to
turn him into a but yet it's like he
clearly had some [ __ ] reasons I mean
he sounds like he had some schizophrenic
and it really does sound like I mean
they put him in a mental hospital so
clearly they knew there's something
matter with him but obviously not enough
that they kept him in there because
that's probably what they should have
done but yeah so the rest of the family
is like we don't know you're talking
about your mom was totally fine to you
she didn't do any which he should I
don't know what your deal is he came up
for parole again in 2015 and was denied
again at which point he attempted to sue
the parole board because he said they
were violating his constitutional rights
to kill his grandma and drink her blood
I suppose but he lost the judge was like
yeah I don't think so what's that I
don't know what his argument was like
gee you know I mean Oh cuz you guys
aren't letting me out I just feel like
crazy you're in jail man I mean that's
the point of you being in jail as you
can't get out unless we tell you that
you can get as crazy you know yeah I
mean it's in a way like I don't feel bad
for the guy
but it's like he's clearly a nut because
he might they'll endanger other people
that's what I mean you can't let him out
it's like I just wish that they had kept
him in the institution because it
clearly where he belonged because he
really does seem to believe this [ __ ]
that he is a very old vampire and he
still seems to believe it even nowadays
yeah so I don't think there is any they
should just keep him in a hospital yeah
I'm worried about it I don't know but
yeah worry about all right so uh let's
that's probably about the first half of
the show
all right and you're probably getting
down to the bottom yeah man look at look
at how much he has look how much I have
all because I have to talk more because
I'm working on because I have the note
yet you know so I can't just like stop
every time because then they'll be like
all this dead air while you're like just
sitting there I'm just like sorry I'm
gonna have to make that next one a light
one Cosette that one there's I know by
the time we get to the end of this
you're gonna be like ah you're just
gonna be like doing all kind of crazy
you'd be falling over in the chair not
know ever know I hold it together dennis
is gonna have to like chastise you if
you leave travel times a man needs a
drink you know I don't know if I should
listen to advice from Dennis Rader I
told him I said on when it's like
holiday show when it's Christmas we need
to get him a little bitty Santa hat yeah
I think he needs a hat anyway cuz look
how his head is just so bulbous yeah all
right so we are going to take a break
right now when we come back we'll do
kind of like a longer segment where we
will talk about rod Ferrell and his
vampire clan and we'll also talk about
the vampire of Sacramento Richard
Trenton chase yeah so we'll be back in
just a minute
you love true crime I love true crime
and I've spent the last three years
compiling a series of the most
intriguing unsolved murders of the 20th
century it's called the faceless villain
and volume three is available now
featuring such fascinating cases as the
Caddy murders the carry babies case the
Frog Boys the al-qasr murders and the
inokashira park dismemberment
the faithless villain volume three is an
involving exploration of unsolved slang
spanning the years from 1980 to 1999
pick up your copy and print or eBook
formats on Amazon or download the
audiobook version from audible.com and
get ready for a chilling journey through
modern crime history
way too risky response given his current
situation it's pressed until conditions
change we also briefly see a gun the
waitress same kind of brightest I'm
different green approach we also learned
that like Sam too bright oh my goodness
we gave the kiddies catnip oh wow
[Laughter]
they're having to roll off yeah they
have a rollup oh I feel like I should
rate them like at the Olympics eight
point five look at you guys go rollin so
fun you guys are hilarious
where are you going Beijing you're going
out of frame you're just scooting all
the way over there yeah Wow
[Laughter]
drugs are cool Dan Beijing's over
Beijing's having a good time don't you
guys fight yeah good girl fook
don't let her pick on you like that no
she's bigger bigger Oh fluffier all
right we're back talking about more
Vampire Killers yeah I'm in another
drink but this was weaker thank you I
appreciate this cuz otherwise you'll
just be like oh yes no that was [ __ ]
ringing my bell there incoherent
I know half the damn audience is lit
though too they're telling me they're
drinking there's ten VPN works we're
inspiring alcoholism yeah yeah I just
get a drink and listen do you guys a lot
of you people just fall asleep good it's
all entertainment people well yeah
is infotainment yeah sort of
info yeah story tainment yeah so now
we're gonna get getting more into like
these bigger cases of better than
Vampire Killers we're gonna talk about
rod Ferrell yeah right vampire clan yeah
now this one I remember hearing a lot
about this one because this M even
though he's not originally from here
this happened in Eustis which is only
about 40 miles from here so that's where
the murder happened
that's what Candice Liz yeah that's
where yeah that's where the lawyer was
that you weren't sure
so rod Ferrell was originally from a
little [ __ ] town called Murray
Kentucky
now there's I was watching a documentary
about this case earlier it's on YouTube
I'm not sure if it was like I don't know
the crime Channel or whatever the hell
it was but then somebody did what about
it and I'm watching it and this town
where they live I'm sure this
documentary was several years old but
it's like I don't know I got a real
satanic panic vibe from like these old
people like all the kids parents like
other people like a businessman that
owned like a skate race skating rink in
town or something like that and they
were just talking about you know how
there was like satanic cults or vampire
cults and they would all like then look
they would all hang out right here by
this corner I'm like oh you mean that's
like where all the gods would hang out
or goth kids is what they were yeah
that's what I mean it's like yeah one of
them killed somebody but yeah it's you
know so it just seemed like there was
kind of this moral yeah more mainstream
people kill people yeah and it's like
you bet like rap music kill lots of
people
well the thing is it's like people that
look all kind of ways kill all kinds of
you so it's like but people only make a
big deal out of it a little bit if you
look a little bit different yeah well
what was funny is that and we were
around during that time you head to gam
Columbine shooting and somehow the
Columbine they call them the trenchcoat
mafia yeah they kind of like they kind
of had a goth look those two kids but
not really they actually liked kfdm
which is another bad it actually a good
very good van yeah
and they hung out with goth kids though
if you looked at their little little
pack that hung out with but they didn't
all kill people they're just just the
two key eyes did yeah you know and but
anyway yeah they're always pointing out
the [ __ ] oddest looking ones right
but statistically the oddest looking
ones these goth kids actually were the
safest ones yeah yeah statistically they
wouldn't bother you and honestly they're
the artsy fartsy yes honestly growing up
in that subculture it's like those
people tended to be a lot nicer yeah
normal looking kids as well in general
growing up the way I did I'll tell you
everybody knows true you are not gonna
get your ass kicked by a goth kid you
just [ __ ] work no taken by a jock
yeah most likely yeah and we did I did
Jack's like me well I didn't but like
some friends of mine did yeah but yeah I
had that damn Sigma male way of [ __ ]
you know what I mean getting around to
getting around [ __ ] well I'm an alpha
male gone wrong saying language of them
[ __ ] off too
I knew what they were coming from so I
but I knew the dynamic between all these
American subcultures yeah you know and
you know I was probably the same way in
Australia probably I don't know if it's
the same way in England but probably
through most of the Western world it
kind of have a lot of that same dynamic
although I heard that British high
schools nothing like American high
school
I don't know from know what I've heard
about it and like I said my ex-husband
was British it sounded fairly similar
they don't have cheerleaders evidently
well no they don't have a lot of the
cultural [ __ ] well they don't have like
yeah that that whole sports thing like
sports they have a lot of sports but
it's usually like separate and and I
heard that you have sports like in your
town but that's not like a school so I
heard that British people thought that
the idea of high school kids driving was
just something out of the movies no high
school kids in the US drive and
evidently that's something that in
Europe they didn't think that that was
actually happened I had a car I was too
poor to have a car you were poor yeah I
had a car yeah good luck my friends that
cars yeah well in the Michigan
in the high school in Michigan that I
had that I went to 11 to 12th graders
all had cars yeah Mosca I went to kind
of like an upper-middle class high
school just because I kind of got lucky
where I lived but it's like um cars were
not expensive most of them bad Garcia
these cars were seven eight hundred
maybe 1200 dollar cars they were not
talking about you know nine ten $20,000
cars these were you know like old
beaters yeah you know I see good car for
[ __ ] 500 bucks yeah well and
sometimes they would get at least okay
sometimes the you know the teenagers
like when they turn 16 or 17 like their
parents would give them an old one like
if they're gonna buy a new one so it was
just like a hand-me-down hand-me-down
call type of thing like you know I have
that car might be a nice damn car yeah I
mean I made a lot of more old but you
know they still ran into in 86 and 87
there were guys at car there were guys
at high school they had the damn Buick
Grand National which was a badass car
today
you see Corvettes you would see [ __ ]
convertibles but you saw jalopies - yeah
but you just you know you might see a
badass Corvette Stingray yeah owned by
seventeen year old kid yeah some trim -
okay just way it was well a lot of kids
had jobs - yeah jobs so usually just
like shitty fast-food job yeah but you
know they were still living at home so
that was just like paper insurance and
women right but I heard some British
people asking I don't on YouTube one
time do do American girls really wear
cheerleader outfits well--there's yeah
they don't have like that relationship
one they don't have American football
that's not a thing
I mean they've heard of it they do have
it on TV over there but it's not like a
huge thing that they watch you know they
have soccer and rugby and that doesn't
really have like it's they don't have
like that hold football pep rally they
don't have a badge and they're they're
out there doing the acrobatic [ __ ] man
tell you man American high school was
the [ __ ] and it still is the [ __ ] it
probably always will be the [ __ ] if you
live if you're going to high school in
the right place and the cheerleaders
wore their uniforms that price ate twice
a week when you say well if it was in
football season yeah we know the
practices
yeah if they were and then there's all
the cheer rallies remember all those
well that's what I was gonna say that
they had pep rallies and [ __ ] like that
and like I said a lot of them had
practice after school or you know from
what I remember they trained all year I
was adjusted which is that long ago it
wasn't it wasn't just football season
they trained all year yeah cuz because
they trained up for that season but I
remember they were all just dying to
become cheerleaders there's a certain
caliber of girls back down back then in
the 80s but I remember that [ __ ]
tryouts I couldn't remember him here I'm
talking about it who was gonna be it was
a [ __ ] social club well yeah and in
those days they had to be hotties
basically yeah there's the only way and
they were in they and they they actually
taught him [ __ ] they were acrobats they
were doing flips and yeah that was a lot
of yeah it wasn't like just like oh yeah
with pom-poms and like back in the old
days it's not they actually have to do
like I had to do [ __ ] flips and pyramids
and yeah you know [ __ ] like those kind
of high judgment catching people and
[ __ ] you know I even in those days I
wasn't into that [ __ ] I still respected
him yeah because they were athletes yeah
that's still athlete acrobats yeah
that's exactly what it was but yeah I
mean what you see in the movies you know
high school type movies that is fairly
active I mean it's obviously like a
little bit you know and if your
exaggerated for movies if you're not an
American if you want the gestalt of
American high school to this day I would
probably say that damn that movie Grease
[ __ ] pretty
it hasn't changed it hasn't changed much
and you know even in the eighties that
Greece pretty much called it that's what
it felt like I was gonna say more like
Breakfast Club that too or there's some
about Tom Knight you want the more about
some about that [ __ ] Olivia
newton-john John Travolta grease
something bout those songs and the
feeling of that movie is what it felt
like to be in high school
mine was more Heather's yeah yeah you
know well I was with the high school in
between Brazil and you know Brazil and
Detroit and in Detroit it was just
Griese yeah because they were all
automobile industry people yeah children
of automobile industry it was just like
that yeah like I said - more like
Heather's well that's why that's why
when Heather's came out so I think
Heather's came out either the year
before I graduated or the year I
graduated I think was 89 or 90 and when
that came out me and all my friends were
like oh [ __ ] man that's like yeah I mean
it's exaggerated obviously but it's like
yeah that was kind of one of Breakfast
Club - yeah Breakfast Club a little more
woods because Heather's was kind of like
you know you have the four main girls
they were like super super they had like
those coordinated outfits and like all
that other kind of [ __ ] certain elements
are pretty in pink yeah I felt that yeah
III kind of related to Molly Ringwald's
character in that yes because she was
kind of broke and had like you in store
clothes and they made fun of her because
of that stuff so I could like relate to
that you know what I mean no that's what
that's why I related that movie yeah
although she had a phone in her room and
I'm like helpful yeah how pork in that
[ __ ] beat you have a car and a phone in
your room yeah that [ __ ] poor I had a
phone in my room it was all on the same
line as everybody else that's yeah
exactly that's really didn't know you
just plug it in yeah you know but they
wouldn't let you could make
long-distance calls back in those days
well and people could like pick it up in
the other room and listen to this what
you were saying yeah so it's like it
wasn't like having your own phone no but
yeah so we're talking about dynamic
between Goths and the [ __ ] normal
society at that time yeah you had a lot
of the old fogies looked at looked at
goth kids like it was something really
unusual but they just didn't understand
what they were seeing they didn't erst
and I really did get that feeling from
this rod Ferrell documentary because I
know these people and like I said I'm
sure it was several years old a you know
the murders happened and what 96 or
something like that and you know it
happened in Kentucky this little bitty
town in Kentucky which you know look
pretty backwards I'm not gonna you know
lie but they were still talking like it
was like early eighties you know satanic
panic kind of time it's like they'd see
a kid you know of kid wearing like black
clothes with like black fingernails and
they think they're like evil incarnate
we talked about a research and [ __ ] like
that this is the boomer perspective of
x-gen
that's part of it you know some of those
boomers who had a real they were they
were very much influenced by the 50s I
mean they really cared about how people
looked I mean they they didn't want you
wearing black clothing they didn't want
because it meant something to them it
didn't really anything to us couldn't
wear yellow on Tuesday that meant you
were gay but boomers were [ __ ]
bizarre they still are bizarre well your
your hair is green what does that mean
yeah I guess if that has some kind of
significance because it had a
significance to them yeah colors of
things I guess like you know I like to
wear black all the time my mother was
like you why are you always wearing
black only hoods wore black and that
[ __ ] off looks like it never even
occurred to me it's like I just like
black it's like when I go to the store
to buy Clif you look at people that are
just colorful dressed kind of more
colors they got on them these are clowns
clowns wear a lot of [ __ ] colors
whether they're clowns are not okay you
read into what I just said is the
listener the more colors on a person the
closer they are to a clown I don't like
a lot of color I don't like a subdued
colors subdued [ __ ] and had to be loud
and nothing confusing I'm not a fishing
lure I'm not trying to evade predators
or [ __ ] like that you know I mean that's
what allowed that spot it's like a World
War one but a naval camouflage called
dazzle look that [ __ ] every [ __ ]
color every [ __ ] pattern it's all
clashing that way you can't you don't
know what the [ __ ] it is your seat you
don't know is the [ __ ] it is you're
seeing and you can't hit it that's what
that color is all about I don't know
what it is man it's like to be honest
it's if anybody asked me like would it
meet that's that's why that it's a
meaningless question like asking
somebody like you said like boomers and
stuff like that that would ask like our
generation like what does it mean yeah I
was like it means I like black clothes
yeah
David that must mean something it
doesn't it didn't know yeah it's like I
just when I was a kid I was like really
into like witchy stories and ghost
stories I really liked The Addams Family
David I just wanted
look like Morticia well they were
growing up they were growing up in the
60s they were coming out of the fifties
environment in the 50s environment you
can go look at it you can watch
interviews of people that went through
the 50s and they'll tell you what the 50
were 50s and the 60s were like they were
very regimented the United States is
very much like Japan at that time if you
could really understand the widget pan
was went to high school with some
Japanese students
everything is very ritualized so
everything does mean something
everything's very controlled there isn't
much in individuality you know and
that's the way they work so if you were
black if you wore all black then you're
some kind of a hood that meant something
Satanist you're saying this - right yeah
that was clean color you know a lack of
color it's very slimming and you can do
things with it
well yeah and the nice thing about it
that one gray yeah like you can do [ __ ]
it goes with them goes with everything
you can have most of your wardrobe is
black and then you could just have a
couple like little looks serious kind of
formal you know what I mean it doesn't
stand out you can vanish in a crowd you
know just yeah but it doesn't mean
anything I mean I saw attics it's a
that's what I mean that that's exactly
what it was yeah I mean to me like the
whole goth scene says it doesn't mean
anything I don't think it was a fire
nothing like that I just thought it was
cool-looking and the music it was cool
goth was always a steady yeah that's it
light that's like a big part they really
come at his family as family the
monsters I think that's what I mean like
that was one of my earliest influence as
a kid I just look like [ __ ] a maila
Nurmi also known as vampire diarrhea she
was probably the original goth aesthetic
woman yeah and she got it for me at his
family cartoons yeah as 50s that's where
that's always where come I can't believe
she was like walking around looking like
that in the 50s that is so [ __ ]
awesome
she had like the first [ __ ] Chelsea
as far as I know yeah hairstyle yeah
with all shades just bangs and she
looked good like it was badass lookin
and I was like a man and that was like a
long time I got fifty something it's
[ __ ] killing me that she was walking
around she was way way hit over time
California scene hung out with James
Dean James Dean didn't like her
eventually kicked her to the curb she
was a little bit of a nutcase but she
loved it yeah she was stylistically
ahead of her time very yeah way ahead of
her
yeah I have a baby what's Ronnie is that
her aesthetic got picked up by the
mexican-american community yeah and all
the cholo girls with their eye makeup
and yes all based on what things are
seeing from Mela and from the fifties
era
yeah love you don't know that I can see
that yeah there's a lot of Mexican and
there's a lot of Gothic look in Mexican
American female fashion yeah oh yeah oh
yeah and from that cuz it's LA yeah yeah
so yeah so rod Ferrell is kind of like
in this little but [ __ ] town in Kentucky
he's an Yvonne De Carlo was Mexican yeah
okay like I'm Lily monster she's Mexican
well a lot of deaths they did that a lot
back then like oh this actress in simply
click it [ __ ] wasn't it like Rita
Hayworth and stuff like that and if you
were Mexican or Central American or
something like that maybe America they
change your name they would dye your
hair blonde or wet or whatever they
would change your name so it didn't
sound so ethnic yeah you know I mean so
a lot of those actresses were actually
mexican-american mexican-american
mexican-american who were a heavy into
Hollywood going back to the [ __ ]
golden age yeah just a lot of people to
never ever then know about they just
changed the names also change their name
and I've heard they bleach their skin to
but and then of course you know [ __ ]
Ricardo montalban's sexy [ __ ]
ratha con Mexican you know he kind of
pulled himself off as some kind of a
Spaniard nah Tijuana yeah yeah well like
I said it's it's just kind of like if
you're gonna be an actor you gotta
likely invent yourself so you got to
have to leave you like the Best Exotic
position make it dance that's right yeah
that's like you know although you can't
get away with it nowadays because nobody
knows every internet everybody but back
then you could you could just like make
a bowl identity for yourself and no one
would be the wiser
so he so he's in this town I called
Murray Kentucky and he had a single mom
and I guess I don't think he ever really
knew his dad because I guess that the
dad left when he was still a baby
so like when he was just a month old or
something like that so he never seen he
got raised by a single mom I think he
was a Sondra Gibson or something
so he starts to get a little bit older
and he gets into vampire the masquerade
that card game which I never played that
it was really big though man my cousin
[ __ ] a story about that [ __ ] coming
out of Man Ray even his back in the 90s
yeah I was got out you know and like my
cousin lived in in her right side in New
Orleans and he was like dude you play if
you have prior masquerades like no man
that's the first time I heard of
live-action role-playing I thought that
was a dorky [ __ ] every dark you see he
was probably 13 do you play that as a
man you play that [ __ ] I'm talking about
but they had some dudes that lived out
mill nowhere that didn't have clubs that
that was their very yeah what else card
game you live in Murray Kentucky what
the [ __ ] are you gonna do that's I think
that's where Farrell first went wrong
that's where he first went wrong he
started playing vampire Azkaban private
master a cause in hand clubs there yeah
that's right Murray Kentucky get some
clubs and you won't have these problems
cuz people will have a place to go
playing in a club there's a social scene
and they keep each other in [ __ ]
check and stop all the dork ISM halo so
the dork ISM they'll also step on the
dicks of any criminal ISM that comes you
know I mean like this weird thing yes I
am a vampire and I'm gonna go kill some
people
David lad out you stop it in a real goth
club yes
well especially back then at me back
Danielle I mean [ __ ] door
particularly Goths in the 80s and 90s or
[ __ ] are very well known for their
differing contempt [ __ ] for people
that weren't like mommy Ranger some
[ __ ] it's not as bad as that anymore
there are a lot more chill nowadays yeah
but yeah back then it's like everyone
was just like it's up your ass yeah you
couldn't like wear the wrong thing if
you had the wrong shoes or something
said the wrong thing they was dating
your face but they would like say a
bunch of [ __ ]
yeah there's like I'll talk about you it
was like Mean Girls but yes so yeah so
he gets into vampire the masquerade cuz
like he said it was nothing better to do
um so he gets more into that and he
starts going around telling people that
he's a 500 year old vampire named
Vassago yeah which I think Yamaha made a
damn motorcycle called it for this saga
that's called a varuga so he was hanging
out with these friends they interviewed
the friends that he had hung out with
like before he went on his murderous
rampage and um they seemed like dorky
but nice enough you know what I mean
it's like they were from Kentucky and
they obviously wanted to get the [ __ ]
out of this town and they were talking
about how the town was all red next and
like everyone was making fun of them and
you know they got beat up and [ __ ] like
that which you know I feel that I get
where you coming from
rednecks did not have the proper context
for Gotha know they really didn't know
as well especially not back then and
it's layout they still kind of don't
that's true I think all though I think
it's a more guy friendly we've run
across rednecks we were [ __ ] totally
decked out for the club they loved it
yeah we don't get a lot of abuse anymore
it's not like the 80s and 90s no I was
at the remember us at the gas station in
that 4x4 ball that's right damn law had
mud all over it my doll they were they
were they were [ __ ] the law they were
a long crew dude you look badass
thanks man what do you do you know I'm
hosting the club now oh man yeah we're
that yeah they were super into you yeah
but back in the 90s I de product got my
ass kicked if I was [ __ ] 20 well yeah
yeah it happened a lot it happened a lot
of my friends it's like even if you were
just like walking down the street like
to the club or whatever it's like people
would throw [ __ ] out of their cars at
you you know what I mean what they
wanted and it's like you freak yeah
maybe like their own beer cans of [ __ ]
it was awful
but yeah so now is now it's like I guess
because people have like a more like a
context like you said of what it is so
they know that it's not scary or
dangerous or anything like that so a lot
more people are like appreciative of it
yeah you know even though it's kind of
weird
it's good sometimes we'll be waiting to
get in the bar and like people are
coming up oh and then they'll want to
take pictures and then they're just like
too complimentary and then it just it's
weird and you want them to go away
yeah but it's better than getting your
butt kicked I guess yeah you know yeah
so yeah so he's going around saying he's
a 500 year old vampire named if a saga
now he had been hanging out with these
friends who all kind of lived in this
scuzzy house in Murray Kentucky now
apparently one of the things that kind
of caused them to have a falling-out was
he apparently he picked up he found a
kitten in the woods or something like
that it was alive and he picked it up
and he was playing with it and he said
according to him because this wood there
was part of an interview on this
documentary that I watched he said it
was a kitten like clawed him you know
like almost and he got mad because he's
like oh you ingrate like I picked you up
and like you just like clawed me but
that's like cats yeah that's - and so he
takes the kitten turns it over like on
his butt and then like threw it against
a tree and killed it like Burke gets
back and this was like in front of his
friends and they were just like yeah nah
man they're like and then they were kind
of like not friends anymore yeah
so then dick yeah cuz it's like they're
like look we like to drink each other's
blood and like play vampire games and
you know say were this that and the
other thing but come on that's like
killing it that's like serial killer
[ __ ] you got my he would he got his ass
whipped if I was around there that's
what I like I said and anybody sorry yes
it's like that's that's not it's a sign
of a [ __ ] that's a sign of a [ __ ]
[ __ ] yes why me do that to a little
defenseless and here's the deal you know
I'm not okay I'm an ex hunter and I
would go out and hunt deer right now
alright but I just got certain standards
yeah oh man quick clean kills only for
food yeah I mean I don't believe in
trapping okay even there's the little
tennessee girl what's her name Hannah
Hannah stepmother and she does those
outdoor stuff I saw her trap and wreck
Coons and I didn't really like that I
don't like any kind of trap and I find I
don't neither I find trapping to be
unsporting yeah okay
at least of mammals trot lining [ __ ]
like fish fish or robots yeah I'm not
really that weird out [ __ ] fish you know
that mean you eat them all right but
trapping these mammals and then going up
and executing them and just you know I
mean just just to fur and [ __ ] like I
don't believe in my kid I couldn't do
that I mean if I was if I needed a fur
coat to survive the coming winter and
then the wild I couldn't understand that
but but just doing it for the sake of
doing it yeah you know I don't like it I
don't like that [ __ ] well because all I
can think of is like and I've killed
many animals but I ate all of them well
any were game animals not pets and and
I'm starting to see [ __ ] like raccoons
as pets you know what I mean because
they're our friendly little [ __ ]
creatures the same thing with black bear
they're basically very friendly
bolon raccoons are pretty smart too yeah
I'm not into that
yeah trap and [ __ ] racks is well and
I don't like I even don't like you know
what every now and then like I go down
the YouTube rabbit hole for watching
like you know funny cat videos and stuff
just like we all do but I even don't
like the ones where people are like
deliberately scaring their cats or like
stressing their cat yeah just a maybe
yeah just to make them do something
funny yeah it's funny but I don't think
you should be like stressing your cat
out like that yeah because it's
different I don't even like pranking a
person and I don't like being pranked
but at least a person knows like
cognizant knows it's a prank the cat
doesn't know it's like the cat's just
like [ __ ] stressed out and it thinks
why are you being so mean to me you
[ __ ] I thought you were my friend and
then you're like stressing to get out I
don't understand why you would do that
yeah I wouldn't do that it's like I feel
bad if I do something because sometimes
I'll scare her accidentally cuz I don't
know she's there or something like that
I feel bad about that I just think it's
a sign of a morally bankrupt and
subhuman person to kill aim to kill
creatures and to make creatures suffer
needlessly yeah what that's what I mean
why would you have an end to that [ __ ]
because it's why I'm very anti China
with the way that they treat animals
there's a lot of bad [ __ ]
but in China I've said it a couple times
on the show you can just google it
DuckDuckGo Chinese animal-cruelty see
the way that they handle animals for
slaughter and [ __ ] and I just man skin
and dogs alive and let them walk around
they think that pain makes meat taste
better which is a [ __ ] backwards
[ __ ] concept so they torture the
things that they eat man that's just see
I just I couldn't do that and like how
you go I eat but it's like I don't those
animals are all clean slaughtered
instant kill that's what I mean like
don't yeah as long as they don't suffer
just don't make it suffer I don't know
the Chinese are taking it to where
they're torturing them to make them
taste better
that's just which that does not work
that doesn't well that that's that
that's an ignorant
that's a stupid magical thing yeah it
doesn't it doesn't make the meat more
tender yeah we have spice
they have tenderizer we have things we
have things you don't have to do that in
our well I don't think it ever worked to
show some kind of a damn folklore that
they believed in yeah and now they just
I don't understand how somebody can't
have empathy for a mammal I can cut it I
can cut a fish heads off yeah but a fish
is not a mammal and fish has a very
primitive nervous system they're very
much like a robot or a machine they
don't you know I mean but to do that to
something that was a house pet like a
cat or a dog man I will [ __ ] you up you
[ __ ] crazy that's what I mean and
that's why any time and and this happens
a lot with these types of killers and
[ __ ] like that and it was weird because
like I'm watching I watched a couple
documentaries like a watchman on rod
Ferrell I watched one on Richard chase
and stuff like that and they were
Chinese because a lot of them killed
cats when they were kids and some
psychiatrists think this because they
see a cat is like a female like a symbol
of female females that they can't get or
they you know what I mean so that's all
like how they start out but it's like
they the guys had the weirdest thing he
said something like oh you know torture
animals and stuff like oh a lot of kids
do that I'm like do they yeah I don't
believe that I don't think they do but
it's like oh when it gets to a point
where you're like killing cats and stuff
I mean maybe like you know maybe burning
and
with the [ __ ] yes fashion bugs and maybe
that glass with a magnifying glass with
ants and [ __ ] like that yeah my brothers
and [ __ ] did that but it's like I'm I'm
talking about like [ __ ] you know cats
and dogs it's like no I don't think you
I grew up with a bunch of bad ass little
boys and none of us ever hurt cats or
dogs no we knew that those were pets
yeah just bugs yeah that's like [ __ ]
with bugs and stuff but yeah bugs are
machines I even feel bad about that well
I don't feel bad about killing
cockroaches because [ __ ] jizz that's
what we were [ __ ] with cockroaches
and ants I feel bad but I feel bad about
hurting spiders though I like spider I
don't I know you don't like spiders I do
though because they eat roaches and
anything roaches in my book insects
arthropods and [ __ ] mammals ok
mammals are too closely related to us
they have emotions I know just look at
their little faces yeah I just look at
their faces and they that you you can
read human emotions in them well [ __ ]
are count like talks to like answers
your questions in chess yeah seriously
so you should you shouldn't have to kill
you should not definitely not kill them
for no reason for food I can understand
it but you don't torture them yeah if
it's like the zombie apocalypse your
wife to death right yeah anything like
that
ok fine but and there are some animals
that have evolved as prey animals like
all those herd animals evolved with very
high reproductive rates because there
were always big cats and dogs and [ __ ]
like that eating them so we're talking
about deer and antelope and water
buffalo and buffalo cows and [ __ ] like
even though cows are artificial
creations of humans but stuff like
that's meant to be eaten all right but
you still don't torture those yeah cuz
why would you yeah there's no reason
there's no reason to torture an animal
no and that's why this makes me so angry
and particularly and I like dogs too but
it's like any time I hear about a person
that like did something bad to a cat I
just like I don't understand it no I
don't understand it we got to get back
to the story
so yes so after he slams a kitten
against a tree you guys all his friends
were like just
ya know let's let's not be friends with
that guy anymore so he decides that he's
gonna go and form his own vampire clan
as he called it because he's not super
original old vizago goes and tries to
find Yamaha his phone
acolytes that perhaps will not mind his
kitten murdering yeah so he gets this
other guy named Howard Scott Anderson a
girl named charity Keesee and a girl
named Dana Cooper um they were all from
kind of like broken homes and stuff like
that I guess it was a lot of the [ __ ]
goes a lot of poverty and whatnot in
this town so you know a lot of single
mothers and you know drunks and stuff so
he kind of becomes the leader of this
little group now he seemed happy for a
while but then his mom decides that she
is going to move from Murray Kentucky to
Eustis Florida which I said it's only
about 40 miles from here because that's
where her boyfriend at the time lives
and her mom is kind of a scenester she's
kind of a goth chick herself from what I
understand well I read in a couple of
different sources I don't know how true
this is but I heard that she was the one
that kind of got broad into like vampire
the masquerade and like all the and race
[ __ ] and all that kin yeah and evidently
she was into that and evidently she
looked very young and acted very young
so she was almost kind of like a friend
of theirs that's how I remember that's
how she ended 30 young she did look
pretty young in the documentary and I
don't I don't remember what year that
was from it was you know but Ken has
told me that back in the in the very
early part of this whole thing when it
started in other words at the time that
there talked about right here is that
the mom actually was like friends with
all the kids that there wasn't a big
difference in age or maybe she was like
the little mom so what you're talking
about it's kind of like you know kind of
kind of like some of the scenes tours
that we know like Sonya and stuff like
that yeah pretty young I think she was
only 18 or 19 years old when she had him
yeah so they're like in their 30s but
they're still partying yeah and they're
partying with their own kids right and
they're all kind of like doing the same
thing which is kind of weird but not as
weird not really under that
circumstances yeah cuz I don't find it
that weird [ __ ] we
we know certain scenesters that are our
age and every now and then their kids
show up to the club yeah I mean we have
a lot of friends we have some funds that
are older than us yeah we have some
friends with you know with kids that are
grown yeah that are old enough to come
out with them yeah and we'll come out
with they don't really hang out with him
per se in the club but they'll break
down you know and they'll bring their
own friends like their own age so it's
like two different cliques yeah but yeah
like I said it's I don't think it's all
that weird yeah so so he gets these so
he gets to UM he has to move to Houston
where the mom's boyfriend lives and this
is where he meets Heather Wendorf now
apparently he really liked her at the
time I think she was only 15 at the time
if he was only 15 or 16 and they kind of
had a little bit of a relationship going
there and he was gonna like induct her
into the vampire clan and everything but
then apparently the mom and the
boyfriend broke up so then he gets
yanked out of Huestis and he gets taken
back to Kentucky so he like he's so he's
back in Kentucky but he kind of keeps in
touch with Heather still who was back in
Eustis and they've just been talking on
the phone and whatnot
now Eustis actually is pretty cool
actually ride up there quite a bit yeah
it's not like I said it's not far for
Mary
yeah it's not far from here and it's
farms and mostly horse farms and houses
and upscale condominiums so you're not
talking about ghetto nice place is used
yeah it is actually a nice it's it's
rural but it's like you know right not
rural in the sense of like meth labs or
yeah not rural in the sense where you
don't have access to anything [ __ ] yeah
Orlando's close to there yeah now even
in the time we're talking about there
was a good goth club down in Orlando
yeah he was a little too young ago
though wasn't he he was yeah back then
right
he would have been too young you would
have had to been 18 right and I think he
was only 15 but his dumb ass went on
this [ __ ] adventure and didn't I was
bad [ __ ] when he should have just
chilled his [ __ ] ass out over in
Eustis and she probably would have
played out all right yeah I mean the
thing about it and we've talked about
this a few times to massage what's going
on at that time
yeah back in the 90s there was a really
good goth scene here that was like there
was good clubs there still is but it's
like you know back then there was good
clubs there was all kind of good shows
marks a good friend of ours was running
visage that's right
and Visayas they were damn commercials
in the news went to prasad and vez he
would yeah who didn't real nice of
massage yeah had he waited a couple
years yeah if you'd have just waited to
grow up a little bit yeah but now he
[ __ ] that up didn't he [ __ ] that [ __ ]
up so for six months he's back in
Kentucky and he's talking to Heather
back in Florida now evidently during
these six months worth of phone calls
she apparently Heather apparently told
rod that her parents were abusive and
that she wrote him letters too and she
said [ __ ] like you know my home life is
hell I wish someone would murder my
parents apparently she said to him so
they thought later on like after what
happened happened they thought that
maybe he kind of picked up on this [ __ ]
that she was saying and thought he was
just gonna come in like captain
save-a-ho
yeah and she sometimes all gotta be
saying take care of your little parent
problem for you yeah ain't that some
[ __ ] yeah this is like I don't know it's
messed up this whole situation is messed
up yeah so November 1996 so rod and the
three members of his vampire clan they
get into a car and they drive they're
gonna drive down to Eustis from Kentucky
to pick up Heather so that they can
induct her into the vampire clan which
had to do with what they call the
crossing over ceremony which is
something that he got with from the
other friends that he was hanging out
with in Kentucky where it's basically
they would just drink each other's blood
just like say some important sounding
[ __ ]
and then they thought that they I don't
know were they vamp I mean yes they were
vampires in the technical sense that
they drank each other's blood they were
did they think that they would act
we live forever no they were [ __ ]
LARPing okay clear on that because some
of them the way they talked not so much
the friends that he was hanging out they
seemed a little more like low-key but
when he talked it sounded like he really
thought that the blood was gonna make
him yeah I talk to Candace about him and
can't you know Candace's mainstream as
hell she's like he was weird
anyone weird you know but I could read I
could read between the lines what he was
as he was a [ __ ] out-of-control young
goth dude who had nowhere to [ __ ] go
who had collected this [ __ ] little
[ __ ] cult little cult of friends that
really put him up on a pedestal and I
really pumped his head up where he
thought he was very special and he got
into this [ __ ] LARPing there's
live-action role-playing stuff and he
started to incorporate that into part of
his identity and that was his stick yeah
okay he had convinced himself as long as
he could convince others that he was a
vampire that he'd be popular he wanted
to save this girl from her family and be
a hero and look important in front of
all of his friends they went over there
and killed this woman
this girl's parents yeah but you know of
course you know being a dumbass
you know I'm being young this [ __ ]
[ __ ] collapsed all around him you
know I mean you can't get away with that
in the modern world yeah especially not
with so many damn witnesses and then the
girl the girl is gonna put up with you
killing her parents yeah even if she's
even if she did like Steve Young and
this is all a winning team on a whim
she's blaming I didn't mean good out
here and killing me out of me
a lot of fish a year old say [ __ ] like
that's just what teenagers do man it's
like all their emotions are all over the
place hormones are all over the place
they say oh you have dumb [ __ ] so then
once he's in custody he has to keep this
front up cuz he can't go oh man yeah you
know I am really mean and I was just
being a dumb you know he has to [ __ ]
keep he has to keep going
he got sunk cost fallacy going on there
right yeah that's the like just lean it
anyway and now he's going from the
[ __ ] soft ass goth [ __ ] culture
into the
hard-ass prison culture so he can't just
go in there little hook that knot on his
head oh no I am the vampire killer he's
gonna do that in prison well yeah he's
to stay alive but just violently like
act like super clear he's good act super
crazy like he's [ __ ] Charles Manson I
yeah and I got that vibe right I feel
like I think there's a lot of I think
there's a lot in common between him and
Charles Manson yeah yeah I definitely
got like a like a similar an abscess II
think Charlie was doing Charlie was five
foot three
that [ __ ] better at crazy when
he goes to prison yeah okay well yeah
that's what I'm saying and and I think
the thing about rod Ferrell and like all
the friends that he was hanging out with
I think some of the [ __ ] too had to do
with this place where they grew up
because it was so easy to shock people
like it just had like all these old
normal people that would like you know
just like flip the [ __ ] out like every
time somebody had black nail polish on
so after a while and I get this cuz I
did this too when I was a teenager it's
like the more people get outraged about
how you look like the crazier [ __ ]
you're gonna do just because it's
hilarious how much they're blowing it
out of proportion yeah and calling you a
Satanist and all this kind of stuff it's
kind of funny so I can see how you know
that might have contributed except he
like took it way too seriously
you know saying Farrell's problem was
ignorance okay
you could let him out of prison now he
would not reoffending is though is he's
guilty of a double homicide you can't
let him out he's gotta stay in there
well yeah dumbass yeah had he just
waited a little bit now growing that
[ __ ] he'd have been up the club with us
that's what I mean it's like I've
thought about that too because that does
seem like us I'm gonna local here you
minute he he'd be down at [ __ ] memento
mori yeah hey how are you guys doing
yeah yeah he would have just been a fine
like you know even normal maybe a little
weird but we're all a little weird well
you ever seen he was younger back then
yeah and it was basically pre-internet
yeah
and he came from poverty yeah
lack of information was a lot of his
problem and big ego but he would have
adapted but I think the Columbine
shooters would have would have adapted
also but can you let these guys run
around have they survived no you can't
yeah no well like I said they killed too
many damn plane that's the thing it's
like you can understand it but you can't
excuse it and it's like they did it it's
too late now
right it's like if you know if
circumstances had been different they
might have turned out it hey I'm not a
snob about homicide there are some
homicides that are forgivable a lot of
it has to do a situation but not
something like with what Farrell did he
know Jerry meanness there's no excuse
you killed two innocent yeah killed two
innocent people's a double homicide
they didn't threaten him they they
weren't fighting him this was not some
kind of disagreement they were
cold-blooded murders yeah he's gotta get
even know them really no right like they
were just like a girl he liked though
that was her parents it's like I think
he barely knew them he got to do his
time yeah maybe you can parole him in
his 60s but when he's too old to be a
threat to anybody well when he's paid
yeah well yeah so like I said he's 15
he's turned 16 in the interim so what
they were gonna know initially or so he
said and so everyone that was with him
said the plan was not to kill her
parents they were just going to break
into the house and steal the keys to the
parents Ford Explorer they had a 1993
Ford Explorer they were gonna steal that
car and use it to like you know drive
somewhere else
wherever it was they were gonna go
because I guess the car they were in
like belonged to one of the friends and
it was like kind of shitty and they
didn't think it would go very far so
that's apparently what the initial plan
was they were gonna kill anybody but
then I guess rod decided now I think I'm
gonna kill him so you trying to impress
people yeah that's exactly what I to do
so he breaks into the garage and he I
don't even think he took a weapon with
him but he found like a short crowbar in
the garage and he took that in there
with him now Richard Wendorf the dad was
asleep on the couch like in front of the
TV
so rod figured and he even said this in
the interview
he said look if the dude like woke up he
probably kicked my ass because he's just
like a little skinny kid so he just
starts beatin the [ __ ] out of this dude
who's sleeping on the couch yeah yeah he
just like beat him with a crowbar like
[ __ ] his he hit him in the chest as well
because he said he'd beat him a bunch of
times in the head and like [ __ ] us
like fractured his skull it was almost a
damn there's almost a damn [ __ ]
Lizzie Borden crime scene really it was
you know what like I saw a close-up and
I wish I hadn't I just saw it
accidentally but I saw a close-up of the
dudes head like the crime scene photo
yeah yeah that was not pleasant because
I'm just like scrolling through the
photos looking for [ __ ] for the video
I'm just like oh damn it's like what no
I'm safe sir and he's not really doing
this girl he's not doing this for
himself he's doing this for all his
[ __ ] followers to show them what
about ass is how good he is and then
what happen that [ __ ] I ended up
getting [ __ ] locked up and everybody
compromised what kind of leadership is
that right all right how about stepping
on your own dick he had everything he
had everything he wanted well that's it
why didn't he just look there initial
plan was just to steal the keys the car
to steal the car if he just stolen the
car okay that's a crime too they
could've just left because slipped away
with the girl he was going with that yes
she went willingly they didn't take her
man it would have been it would have
been very small charges yeah it's like
yeah like I said stealing a car that's
not good but it's like they would have
gotten the [ __ ] out of there they
wouldn't have done any serious time yeah
they wouldn't if there were minors yeah
so it's like you know they probably
would have got written off it's like but
no he had to just live it up in the club
telling these [ __ ] crazy sisters
remember that time we came we stole the
car still really took her he's got her
away from his parents move oh yeah what
yeah it would just been a story to tell
they'd have been totally fine yeah but
it's like I don't understand like what
the [ __ ] this is okay this is a case
where you know I'm convinced that
everybody involved including [ __ ]
Farrell
these were not [ __ ] like totally nuts
psychopath
they were [ __ ] regular kids do it he
did some stupid [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
dumbass
yeah you know that's the thing it's like
this yeah it's like I said I hate I hate
to say this because it's like I don't
want to sound like I'm excusing it no no
he's got this time oh he does yeah but
he does not strike me as the same type
of person as somebody like the next
[ __ ] we're gonna chase his
[ __ ] crazy he was just a crazy
[ __ ] from the outset he wasn't
this tit this kid just seemed like a
troubled kid and just [ __ ] went bad yeah
and he [ __ ] meet us and do good [ __ ]
and just did something really really
stupid
when he could have just like I said he
could have just stolen the car like the
play-doh here's but here's it something
else
Charles Manson made that same
miscalculation Charlie had everything he
[ __ ] won he could have stayed up at a
spawn ranch with all these young girls
and gotten endless [ __ ] [ __ ] he had
everything he [ __ ] wanted yeah why
did he had to tell them to go out and
kill somebody
yeah that's right was like white why you
want to shoot yourself in the dick like
that I don't get it
stupid that is stupid yeah and like I
said rod Ferrell he had three friends
who had a girl who wanted to go with him
yeah he had a vehicle yeah apparently
they had some money they were in an
awesome area they could have just left
they could have just taken on eventually
I guess they'd be hanging out [ __ ]
Paul and Tina and [ __ ] massage massage
and they would have been there doing a
massage reunion and I bar yeah and
because they know the exact scene that
they were around and they would have
been part of that [ __ ] scene I had
[ __ ] Farrell not been such a [ __ ]
dumbass yeah yeah it all could have gone
differently for you because we know a
lot of guys that could have gone that
people we didn't know a lot of people
that could have gone this way yeah they
just didn't they just didn't right
because they're not that stupid
right yeah but yeah so he beats this
sleeping dude to death skulls all [ __ ]
up he said in the interview that he's
like well I beat him a bunch of times in
the head and then I saw that his chest
was still rising and falling like he was
still breathing so I'd like hit him a
bunch times in the chest as well so he's
he dead he's dead and then the mom now
he had actually like
around the house alike case the joint so
he knew like where the mom and the dad
were in the house like I said before he
broke in so he goes in there and then
after he did that the mom uh Naomi I
think they called her were you sad
because that was her middle name she cut
she was in the shower and she came out
of the shower and she saw him and she
like lunged at him and apparently like I
guess she'd been in the bathroom she had
like a cup of hot coffee in her hair and
she threw it on him and then according
to rod she grabbed him like around the
neck and she was like trying to was like
struggling with him and [ __ ] like that
so you know she tried to like whip his
ass justifiably um so Rob still had this
rod still had to cross the the crowbar
and he like pulled it around and he like
started stabbing her like in the back of
the head with it yeah so no Jonny you're
an adult so that eventually killed her
imagine that you're a calm cold
reasonable adult with [ __ ] bills to
pay and [ __ ] to make and they got this
crazy [ __ ] damn card game yeah
that's what I mean it's like like I know
he's got a crowbar and he killed him
adults it's like that's terrible and
stuff but it's like how I know exactly
what you mean because it's like you'd be
like like I said you get out of shower
I'm in the towel I'm like it go my hair
with and a [ __ ] 15 year old stupid
kid he thinks he's a five-hundred old
vampire [ __ ] hair and [ __ ] like comes
in they're like all fur I just felt like
just just knock it off knock it off yeah
that's exactly what every house should
have a guns and what every house I mean
she was like and you could tell that the
mom in this case was just like not
having it because she lunch right at his
stupid ass threw coffee on him and
everything yeah
and he had said like later on he said oh
well I wasn't gonna kill her but then
she like fought back right yeah imagine
that yeah so then he had to yeah yeah so
what the [ __ ] so yeah he kills both of
them he's not thinking this [ __ ] through
spend the rest of his life [ __ ]
locked up behind bars behind the
students just one [ __ ] stupid thing
that you did as [ __ ] is done just
[ __ ] the head he waited a day
it would have passed he probably had a
normal life hilarious so apparently the
bodies of the parents were found by
Heather's older sister Jennifer who she
had been out with her friends and stuff
and I guess she was coming home late she
was like past curfew so she was like
trying to sneak in the house like you do
when you're a teenager and you know
you're out too late
so she sneaks past her dad who was still
on the couch and she didn't realize he
was dead she thought he was just
sleeping and so she like snuck past and
she was like wow that was kind of easy
he didn't even wake up and then she goes
in the kitchen and then she sees her mom
and there's blood everywhere yeah and
then so obviously she calls the cops
she's flipping the [ __ ] out now when the
cops um talked to her she gave them Rock
barrels name yeah because she said hey
you know she's like one Heather's gone
the sister but she's like but Heather
hangs out with this kid named broad and
it's like she for real did not get
kidnapped I think she really like left
of her own volition and look into this
dude because he's like [ __ ] sketchy
so the cops so the sister the older
sister like kind of gave them all the
information they needed and then they
started looking into rods background and
they're like well obviously now they so
the four of them they were in the stolen
Ford Explorer and they drove through
four states in four days in Baton Rouge
Louisiana they ran out of money
at which point one of the girls calls
her grandmother I guess for more money
or for somewhere to stay and the
grandmother who had been following the
news and yeah and the news were like oh
she's like oh yeah I'm come to this
particular Howard Johnsons by the
highway I'll give you some money and
then she called the cops and said where
they were so good on you grandma grandma
so yeah so they come to the Howard
Johnsons like dumbasses thinking they're
gonna get all this money from Grandma
and the cops are there and they had set
a trap for them so they all got arrested
arrested right there underneath that
orange roof I know right
warrants
deal classy yeah and Howard Johnson
still look like that in the 90s I guess
it did he did yeah yeah they had good
fried clams they did I humiliate it two
days ago that we have we did like a
whole big shrimp we have this big huge
like pot that's like this big it's like
it's a man's pot it is it's not six feet
tall it's probably like yeah what three
feet tall yeah two and a half feet tall
yeah it's a real pot so we got we went
to Sam's you know and they have like
bags of three pounds of like big [ __ ]
20k we're just like this little like 20
count pound 20 count yeah so yeah and
they were like how much were they
thirteen nineteen thirteen bucks for
[ __ ] three four three pound pounds
why do big eyes shrimp so I got like six
pounds of shrimp yeah we got like
[ __ ] potatoes little corn cobs
everything to put it all in there with
[ __ ] crab boil you actually not use
that old bay Old Bay seasoning I should
have used I should have used this yeah
we didn't have the saturon bags there's
a lot zestier spicy it is yeah the old
day is a little too mild for me it
sounds good but [ __ ] man that was a that
was a that was a that was a shrimp boil
yeah we said we had like bowls and
plates and everything still on sale I
love we could get some I love seafood
yeah but yeah we haven't done it we're
gonna do a crab boil but the crab legs
were too expensive
yeah but then we saw they had the shrimp
shrimp oh yeah sure I guess that works
too it was cheaper than hamburger per
pound it was it we're getting at it was
like four dollars and 49 cents a pound
yeah for and they like I said there was
a breath there was three dollars now it
was for 49 47 and they were big shrimp -
and nothing's like dinky as little
[ __ ] yeah they were big like in a
restaurant they call those prawns a big
shrimp yeah I think in England a prawn
is a different thing it's a different
species but for
see I thought that when I was over there
I thought prawn was just like
interchangeable with shrimp okay but I
could be wrong about prawn a real
trooper on is a different species that's
huge yeah I see I think it's about half
the size of a good-size lobster tail
yeah Fromme I'm just confused about the
whole shrimp prawn thing cause like I
said I feel like I feel like they're
used like interchangeably they were a
big 21 count prawn yeah shrimp yeah
which is 21 21 of them to a pound that's
pretty big so so they catch these four
idiots now two broad Farrell's credit uh
when he got arrested he actually did
plead guilty to the murders and he said
that none of the others had anything to
do with it so he did kind of like front
for them right he said well the girls
were in the car the other guy just
watched it and do anything you know all
this other kind of crap now Ron Farrell
did actually get the death penalty which
at the time made him the youngest person
I believe in the United States at the
time to be on death row although later
his sentence was commuted to life in
prison in 2000 now one of the other
girls even though he said that she was
innocent that she'd stayed in the car or
whatever I'm not sure if I believe that
or not she was actually convicted of two
counts of third-degree murder robbery
with a gun or deadly weapon and burglary
armed with weapons or explosives
she got 10 and a half years in state
prison the other one got the same
charges
she got 17 and a half years both of them
are have subsequently got out yeah one
of them's around here the cute one black
hair she's pretty and cute she's out
yeah I checked and she's vanished but
she's in our area she's around here
somewhere
yeah probably like I said used to sit
here he rides today uses on his
motorcycle
sometimes cuz isn't that where that
little that bodega is where you get your
hot sauce yeah that obvious now last I
heard she's kind of vanished I thought
she would show up at the club but I
don't think she does I think I wouldn't
recognize her if she did I
she's totally different now I don't yeah
I don't think she's in the same maybe
not because it does seem like this you
know one guy one guy that was kind of
like in with rod like back in the old
days like I don't think he had anything
to do with the murder but they
interviewed him for the documentary he
just seemed like normal urine like he
had kind of gotten over it yeah but yeah
so rod Ferrell still in jail now in what
was a very controversial decision at the
time Heather
whose parents were murdered they let her
go free she didn't get any jail time at
all even though the whole thing was that
she had asked him to kill her parents
but she didn't get well you know and if
any of you guys are out there still
we're local to you you can contact us I
wouldn't mind hanging he wouldn't mind
meeting new people well you know hey he
was the one that if you're cool where he
was the one that did it all yeah
wouldn't mind having him honest they
could always show up I don't care yeah
but I don't know it didn't have anything
to do with it yeah it does seem like a
lot of people were really mad that
Heather got away with it like that they
just like let her go she was a little
kid but yeah like it well so was he but
I mean she didn't yeah maybe like I said
she had written him a letter that said
oh I wish they were dead or something
like that she didn't [ __ ] a lot of I
don't think that she really liked me
understood the gravity of the situation
and I don't really think she literally
meant oh I want you to drive down here
right now and kill them she didn't give
him that okay to do that [ __ ] yeah I
mean you know based on the evidence like
I said teenagers say a lot of stupid
things and you know I've heard of a lot
of teenagers say to their parents oh I
wish you would died you know I feel like
they don't really mean that like if you
really died they'd be upset yeah they
just say that because they're mad and
their hormones are crazy and [ __ ] like
that he just took that [ __ ] way too
seriously so I don't know whatever ended
up happening to her her sister don't
talk anymore evidently
you know not surprisingly because I
guess the older sister kind of blames
her for that [ __ ] but yeah she walked
free the other two girls did their
prison time and they're out one got out
in 2006 one got out
2011 the other guy who was with them he
is not due to be let out until 2032
I don't think he will be 51 years old so
he is also still in prison so that is
the rod Ferrell vampire clan case do you
have any more to add on that I need to
break though all right we're gonna we're
gonna take a break but not for you guys
we're just gonna put like a thing and
then but when we'll come back and talk
about Richard Trenton chase the vampire
of Sacramento all right you doing okay
yeah yeah I'm managing him you're just
like maintaining yeah Dennis Lee he's
looking good look at him he's looking
all dapper yeah he's always wearing that
suit though yeah like I said we need to
get me saying that all right so we're
going to talk now our last case of
vampire killers we're gonna talk about
Richard Trenton chase better known as
the vampire of Sacramento yeah I first
read a story about this guy back in like
93 or four I think it meant 94 yeah yeah
I was in Egypt multinational force
observers with the army enforcing that
embargo on Iraq mm-hmm and somebody
loaned me a book about this case and it
was fascinating case it's it is it is a
good case this case is crazy yeah he was
[ __ ] batshit yeah this one to me this
one was kind of understandable yeah
because he was crazy yeah I mean this
guy legit had some really serious mental
problems he was family
yeah he was oh what'd he call him
schizophrenic yeah he thought that his
internal organs were turned into dust
yeah I mean he would have to drink blood
to keep him from dissolved yeah and like
I said he's really was upside down you
really did seem to believe that so he's
kind of like James Reva in the sense
that you know I killed my grandma
because I thought she was a vampire it's
kind of a similar situation except this
guy has like a much higher body count
yeah he really does have these delusions
and he really does seem to believe that
which you know like I said it's terrible
but some people it's just a little more
understandable than ximena's and then
the sexual motives if you ask me yeah I
mean well it ran around a little 22
shooting people and drinking their blood
and busted in or their houses mm-hmm
women children that was his main thing
yeah he was not real um discerning about
he didn't have like a victim profile
person now and they wasn't sexual well
well there may have been a couple I
think he did sodomized a couple of the
victims like the female victims yeah so
clearly there was kind of set and I have
to say to that one of the main things
and I think a lot of the people that
have looked into his case have kind of
like talked about how he was impotent he
couldn't get an erection even like from
a very young age and he had actually
like seen medical specialists about it
and stuff and they think that maybe that
might have spurred some of his weird
delusions because he thought well you
know blood to your penis makes it get
hard so dry more blood making more blood
well maybe make it work because he was
clearly attracted to women but he
couldn't maintain an erection right and
you know which which is a medical issue
and he didn't even maintain sanity
though it's my first real yeah that was
like nobody does probably the least of
his problems honestly yeah he was
[ __ ] crazy he had schizophrenia
pretty bad a lot of health
hallucinations and delusions yeah he had
like a lot of life really bad delusions
so and he started um so he started
showing signs of mental illness at a
very young age his dad apparently didn't
really do anything to help him but you
see you know was back in the day it's
like dads were just like are just man
out bar so it's like they don't do it
like back in the old days and you know
what I mean and this was 70s I think
yeah I was even like watching a
documentary about him and even you know
a couple of the psychiatrists on there
said you know yeah he probably got beat
by his dad and stuff like that but a lot
of kids did because that's just what you
did back then because they thought that
that was how you discipline them other
than you like mentally scar them for
life but you know what I mean
so the dad is kind of like abusive he's
very strict didn't really you know he
knew that there was maybe something
wrong with it but thought maybe could
beat it out of him or something like
that
so he said Richard chase he displayed
what they call the Macdonald triad which
a lot of serial killers have that is
arson setting small fires bedwetting and
cruelty to animals that is something
that many many serial killers have that
like they said that's it's so common
that they have a name for it it's called
the Macdonald triad and if you have
those three things when you're a kid
doesn't mean you're gonna become a
serial killer but it is like a benchmark
of like sociopathy and like you might
have problems later on and he did have
all three of those things so apparently
when he was a teenager even though like
he went to school and he was like fairly
normal like he had like he was a little
bit quirky but not so bad that like
other people picked on him and stuff
like he had a fairly normal childhood
fairly normal like school life and [ __ ]
like that
but later on he started getting into
drugs particularly marijuana acid stuff
like that which a lot of people were at
the time his dad kicked him out of the
house so he starts getting more into
drugs
starts drinking a lot and I feel like he
probably had a lot of really severe
mental illness anyway and then the drugs
and alcohol just made it worse and like
I said even this documentary I was
watching about him where they had like
all these psychiatrists on they're
talking about they said look that if you
don't already have some underlying
mental illness like taking acid and
stuff despite what like all the [ __ ]
scare mongering films back then would
tell you it's like that's not gonna make
you like go cut people's heads off or so
unless you already have something wrong
with you
they're like if you already have
something wrong with you and then then
you go and do drugs and like drink too
much and [ __ ] like that yeah that might
make it worse yeah what like it's just
drugs it's not gonna do that by itself
my experience most almost all those
drugs are [ __ ] worthless okay
but a couple hits acid can come some
kind of sort of [ __ ] out
it really can almost kind of like
electroshock therapy but that's not
something that you abuse
yeah something you do maybe like well
[ __ ] I wouldn't do it more than once a
year
that's well it's kind of like one so far
once in a while Jeff treat you know
that's how I see it now Joe Rogan says
MDMA is even better I've never tried
I've never done that but if it's
anything like good quality LSD then he's
probably telling the truth of course you
know I had it I had an insight on damn
LSD back of the day yeah through the
universities I'm not gonna talk about my
best friends who were biochemists yeah
you know I could get the message I can
get the good [ __ ] was free yeah we
weren't selling we were just here yeah
well you just had it and you try this
you know you know and that's something
you you can use but you don't abuse it
you gotta be [ __ ] Native American
about that [ __ ] you're walking you're in
the spirit world yeah I got to respect
that [ __ ] and then you come back [ __ ]
you know a wiser and stronger man Steve
that's what that's what I always kind of
liked about those types of particular
drugs yeah that it's not so like if you
do it all the time if you do it all the
time it would ruin the experience it's
like it seems like you just only want to
do it every now and then what's miners
or some particular insight like some
kind of you know what I mean that's what
the shaman would do in the try me or
like what care we got a Edition for that
reason we gotta have a vision go put the
[ __ ] TP up there I need some steam
and a bunch of heat we're gonna go in
there and have a vision you know I mean
they would take some crazy [ __ ] and they
would solve the tribes problems
yeah and that's that's what that [ __ ]
was for but you know it's my
understanding based on dudes that abused
it what happens is is that the more you
take it the less of effect it has you
kind of go through that you put up a
resistance yeah and then if you stay in
LSD land for too long you actually start
becoming a worthless [ __ ]
really more than anything else and you
amount to nothing because it's like a
bomb it doesn't seem like it's not
something you want to overdo it doesn't
even seem like the kind of drug you'd
want to ever do like I can almost I can
see why people would abuse heroin or
cocaine or something like that but
matzot not so much I don't know why
you'd want to do that every day my
[ __ ] black buddies would [ __ ] were
scared to death of LSD Dave they'd like
coke but they they didn't they were
scared to death on LSD
why I don't know something about it that
it in african-american culture and scare
the [ __ ] out of them but there were a
couple of them that I knew that did take
it and they were like oh yeah yeah do
you know what I mean it's something you
have to kind of release yourself yeah
it's a different kind of deal it's it
yeah it's a different kind of yeah
variants right yeah all right I'm not
gonna recommend it to black people so
I'm just gonna leave that I'm just gonna
leave it at that there's a certain
there's a certain angle that it comes it
comes at you at a certain angle that's
some time that can unleash enlightenment
in certain kind of peace if you approach
it in a particular way it has to be sign
to come at it like it's a religious
experience
Nonnie well I wouldn't even say
religious but you have to come at it
like as like looking for insight or
looking for some kind of like no don't
come at it with anything negative don't
don't do that because that'll [ __ ] that
[ __ ] up and don't go in public well yeah
no not at home at home supervision and
also take the next day off work yeah
yeah learn from my mistake it's not I
wouldn't even call it a it was because
I've had many hangovers so our deal
tired very tired oh I don't think I've
ever been that tired before my whole
entire life I can't believe I worked an
entire shift the following day I don't
know how I got MDMA and ayahuasca or
sister even better yeah to get ayahuasca
you got to go to Central America and
that the shamans can give it to you I
would [ __ ] love to try it although
they say it makes there's too much
vomiting yeah I don't like that they say
it makes you very sick but you come back
with a different well just just just
just go on YouTube and search up [ __ ]
Joe Rogan Joe Rogan's done whole shows
on ayahuasca I've always been kind of
curious about it but like I said the
vomiting puts me off you know what I
mean there's certain kind of knowledge
that might you know I mean that there
are certain kind of certain it might be
worth it not any problem throwing up I
know you see I'll throw it in a
heartbeat
I don't like feeling the bother I throw
up like a man I'm just okay baby well
the funny thing about it is that back up
very well he's very calm about it very
calm about he'll just be like well I'm
gonna throw up but he can like wait
until you know I mean whereas like I'd
be like barfing yeah hold on one second
back up everyone move aside movies I put
up the yellow tape okay yeah like he can
like yeah hold it off until he can get
somewhere where it's a person it's
discipline where he can get some
discipline I've said I can sometimes do
that but not always
I don't usually I don't I don't barf a
lot like from drinking anymore yeah it's
probably cuz my liver is just giving up
at this point but yeah so um as I was
saying I I do feel like even though you
know Richard chase yeah he was like on
all the drugs and everything like that
but I don't think it was the drugs that
caused him tonight he like that pick up
in now and then yeah I say that I think
he was already like that and then
because he was already like that he
started abusing drugs and that made his
mental illness worse he was already
crazy
he was already crazy like I said he
already had all that [ __ ] going on from
when he was a kid he was already like
hurting animals he was always already
doing that [ __ ] yeah also when he got a
little bit older he started getting like
you mentioned all of these weird like
delusions like he thought that he had
already done
and he was just like walking around like
he was a zombie or something like that
um he had the impression that his heart
had stopped like that he was just
walking around with no heartbeat um he
would he thought that um that he wasn't
getting enough vitamin C for whatever
reason so he would take a orange like a
whole orange and he would like push it
into his head and he would say like oh
well the brains gonna absorb the
nutrients right like by osmosis or
whatever um he thought that I think you
said this before but he thought that his
skull was like breaking up into pieces
and like moving around like puzzle like
puzzle pieces like inside of his head he
thought his stomach was upside down yeah
um because of the whole thing that he
thought with his skull that's why he
shaved his head at one point because he
wanted to watch that [ __ ] like where all
the skull pieces were going he wanted to
make sure that they were going to the
appropriate place or something like that
this guy clearly like I said he had some
issues he had some weird-ass body
dysmorphia yeah it's weird because I see
huh there's pictures of him and he he
looks like [ __ ] young Peter Murphy
yeah he does he looks like young like
young hot Peter Murphy except mixed with
old meth-addicted Peter yeah if he was
from bouncing goods in mineral shape he
would have been a good-looking guy yeah
he wasn't yeah it's so [ __ ] crazy
it's hard to maintain an attractive
appearance because your diets [ __ ] up
your grooming habits are [ __ ] up yeah
he looked like he was a sweaty
[ __ ] - he did look like he was
costly sweaty and not taking a shower
and greasy yeah like a non shower and
[ __ ] well like I said certain
types of mental illness and particularly
like he said ones that focus so much on
these types of body dysmorphia yeah
where he thought something was like
going wrong with his body all the time
yeah and as I said he also had a lot of
issues and a lot of like documentaries
bring this up that he had a lot of
issues with erectile dysfunction when he
was young like a teenager like in his
early 20s like he would try to date
women cuz he was clearly very attracted
to women but then like he couldn't like
perform sexually couldn't make
I guess he could get an erection but he
couldn't maintain it like long most of
its psychological well yeah that's why
he's dress related he ended up going to
a psychiatrist because apparently he
thought the same thing like he thought
that there was something the matter that
was like causing but I think as that
went on like he did get some treatment
for it but I think as it went on he
started developing this delusion that I
need extra blood right like for dick
hardening purposes I guess that's kind
of that you know that might be
speculation but I do think that that's
kind of like might be was trying to
coming home some kind of explanation for
it
yeah but you know I mean [ __ ] it's
all mental and psychological I mean all
you got to do is just put a woman on a
man and if he she just stares
disapprovingly at him
he's not gonna be able to rock up but
it's just gonna we'll just get him
wheels it away so it's just his State of
Mind was it's a very delicate balance
yeah a delicate but yeah for dude to
rock up what he's just gotta be fun
totally lost in it and he don't give a
[ __ ] and he ain't been thinking about it
it's automatic but if he starts thinking
about it too much or worrying about it
then he won't do it and that's that's a
lot of a lot of it there the some guys
you know when they get to a certain age
of course they have you know
neurological problems or problems with
[ __ ] you know what I mean diabetes
evidently can do it there's a lot of
different things that can you know yeah
affect a man's capillaries because you
know it has to do with [ __ ] blood
flow yeah blood flow in psychology yeah
combination of shootings I mean you know
in psychology plays a large part in in
women's arousal also yeah but it's not
you know it's obviously not I'm not
gonna say it's not as big a problem it's
just not not as a parent it's not as a
parent that's that's the word I was
looking for right just because you know
even if you're looking noticeable for
[ __ ] not rock dust right
exactly like a woman could just kind of
lay there be like whatever I can to this
but okay but you know what I mean sit
and like nothing happens but yeah so
it's kind of like more pressure on
on the other end yeah so Richard Chase
is 25 years old and as I said he'd
started going to a psychiatrist for his
erectile dysfunction among other things
and all his body dysmorphia problems and
he got diagnosed with paranoid
schizophrenia and he was
institutionalized 1975 and evening
because they did think that he might be
a danger to himself and others
hell yeah that motherfucker's paranoid
schizophrenic [ __ ] which was class
look having read that no yes having read
the book of everything that he said and
the kind of [ __ ] that he did
schizophrenic like a [ __ ] you
just can't expect any sense out of this
guy yeah his MO doesn't make any
religion and I'm telling you I'll tell
you something right now and it's like I
a long time ago I saw a documentary
about schizophrenia and they talked to
like a bunch of people that had it and a
lot of people that had it were like they
were pretty normal like when you talk to
them and stuff like that but it scared
me because schizophrenia is something
that it can kind of like it mostly
strikes at a younger age like late
teenage early 20s but it can strike
anyone anywhere you don't have to have a
genetic pretty informal EU don't have
just doesn't necessarily after run your
family it can strike anytime and the
fact that these people were just like
living a normal life and then all of a
sudden they just started to like
developing these bizarre like [ __ ]
light and there was nothing they could
do about it and the scary thing about it
that this is what scared me the most in
this documentary was that the people
they were talking to they knew
yeah they knew that it was crate but
they couldn't help it and it was like
really like heartbreaking to watch it
because they were just like look I know
like all this stuff but it's like when
it overtook them that was like nothing
they could do about it
yeah and that like really really scared
me I'm like oh my god that's that seems
like if it seems like one of the worst
things that could happen to you
consciousness is a [ __ ] tricky thing
it is okay that freaks me out
it freaks me out your consciousness can
be altered by little small [ __ ]
changes yeah and you can start thinking
some crazy [ __ ] and I mean I don't even
like the idea that I perceived like even
something minor I don't even
like the idea that I perceived something
minor incorrectly yeah that like freaks
me out
you know what I mean like look okay
here's an example so we came home from
the movies after we saw a zombie land
and we had got some food like you know
we'd picked up some food and stuff so we
come home and we open the front door and
our cat Beijing
she wants to go outside she likes to run
out the front door she doesn't go
anywhere she just lays on the front
porch so she went out and she laid on
the front porch and I was like okay cool
so I had my hands full I had all the
food and stuff like that so I closed the
door I see her out there on the porch so
then Tom doesn't goes and does whatever
I go to the bathroom I go and like put
all the food down I put like you know
take my shoes off or whatever then we're
all sit in the bed watching Creepshow
we're like eating the burgers and all of
a sudden Beijing runs through our room
and runs to the back a sliding glass
door like she wants to go outside again
Tom's like how did she get back back in
the house right yeah we just let her out
and I'm like yeah she went out I get the
flashlight I walked the perimeter we
thought someone was in the house the
letter ik added because how about you
[ __ ] did she get back in and check the
house uncle almost happened there's
something you know this blows together
our cat teleport yes so I guess she was
outside so I checked the inside and I
checked the outsider
I checked all their windows it's the
garage the attic everything and I'm like
it's all it's all buttoned up there's no
way she could have gotten back in but
then I just had to accept that maybe I
was walking by that door and saw her and
she wanted back in I let her back in and
didn't remember but it bothered me
because I thought to myself look I
remembered that she ran out because I
had my hands full and I closed the door
and I saw her sitting on the porch and
then I went to the bathroom or whatever
and it's like I know I saw that but it
scares me to think that maybe I didn't
see that
well most hasn't happened in a long time
and that's not something that the bus
would do I think what it is is I I saw
her at the door maybe you just let her
and I let her back in without thinking I
can't think of any other non see we have
a glass door our doors glass yeah so she
can go up to the doors is his little
[ __ ]
yeah she just like peeks in through like
hey she must have asked to come back in
and I just didn't remember Thank You
Justin forever cuz I do certain things
just unconsciously like oh you're on
that's well like I said that's the only
access I have my tablet my hand I might
have been doing some of my tablet at the
time you know man I walked by there and
just saw yeah well let her come in I was
like thinking about that all that I had
no idea you know I'm like am I crazy
because I'm sure she ran outside and I
saw her sitting out of the porch I just
saw it that's the only thing I can think
of and then later she was back in the
house and I can't figure out how she got
back in so you know I mean so if my like
imagine that but like multiply 2010 your
whole life was like that yeah like you
just weren't sure what the [ __ ] was
happening what the [ __ ] was real it's
like paranoid schizophrenic thinks
everybody's after them to everything
everything why everything they do
everything they see it's about them and
people doing gangs at them and so that's
what I mean I so I have a lot of
sympathy for people that have it because
I know that it it just like strikes out
of the blue and it seems like a
terrifying yeah and it seemed terrifying
to the people that had it too because
they knew that they had it yeah and like
that seemed really scared well chase was
a [ __ ] nut he didn't know what was
true that's and that's what drove him to
do what he did I don't even think we've
gotten into what he's dead we did yet so
yeah he just got institutionalized this
in 1975 now he was so fascinated with
blood that all the other inmates at the
institution nicknamed him Dracula he
also he while he was in there he tried
to like get a bunch of birds like he
would catch birds like outside the
window of his cell and like try to drink
their blood and shed um he also he
thought that he was being poisoned and
that the poison was turning his blood
into powder and that's why he had to
drink the blood because he thought that
would like liquify his turning in powder
and they thought all absord internal
organs were turned into dust - yeah I
mean before he was institutionalized he
would also like inject himself with
rabbit blood yeah which made him sick
not a core
yeah so now he was in the institution
for a little while and this is another
case where they thought that he was okay
they thought they had rehabilitated he's
fine now so they let him out now he was
released to go live with his mother but
since he was you know over 18 he wasn't
a minor or anything like that so they
said you know you have to go live with
your mother but there was no law like
making him stay there right so um he
actually moved out because he thought
that his mother was poisoning him yeah
so he moved into an apartment with a
bunch of dudes that like friends of his
now they didn't know him all that well
you know I guess they were just like
acquaintances or whatever um and they
all kind of started to get a little bit
upset because he won he was on drugs all
the drugs pretty much all the time
he had like weird habits like he would
like walk around naked all the time he
was always [ __ ] high on something or
other so finally they just all got sick
of it and they told him to leave
um but he wouldn't go so um so the
roommate said okay well then we'll leave
so they all just left him there by
himself because they couldn't handle his
ass anymore because apparently he was
doing some crazy [ __ ] yeah Ron this time
he started to getting into Nazis and he
started getting into guns too he started
to kind of make some kind of connection
between blood and Nazis and the occult
and guns and he started to kind of like
well I think that's a that's a pretty
common symptom of schizophrenia where
they make all these kind of connections
and actions that aren't necessarily
there and we thought he was a Nazi
vampire that's really what this [ __ ]
zombie vampire Christians I thought he
was a Nazi vampire and that the Nazis
knew what they were doing and they
wanted blood - that kind of weird [ __ ]
and
I don't remember what kind of he got a
pistol I thought it I think it might
have been a Ruger 22 Ruger 22 target
pistol which looked a lot like a Luger
yeah so he kind of you know which he is
associated to Lugar's with Nazis that's
how I remember it's been a long time man
yeah so he was gonna go out and put the
shoot people with his fake Luger which
is actually just a Ruger 22 target
pistol and get blood to keep his Nazis
soul alive
good weird yeah like I said he thought
his [ __ ] blood was powder yeah and
then he had to like drink they said he
really liked to pictures of like [ __ ]
concentration camps with all the piles
of the bodies and stuff you know that he
was big into that that's my stop which
was this is in the 70s of course you
know I mean if I can California if I
remember correctly right California I
believe saying and you know this is
[ __ ] hippie filled that time you know
you can't run around you just run around
in an army jacket with a Ruger 22
[ __ ] really but now people trying to
be a nazi vampire yeah Mon now yeah like
something damn that was it in the movie
that we saw the other day [ __ ] with
the pink now he's in World War two
vampire we saw that several several
months ago okay yeah actually maybe
almost a year ago yeah he thought he was
in overlord I guess so Castle
Wolfenstein whatever so so now he's
living alone once again which it's never
good for him apparently to like be alone
because he just gets into more drinking
and more drugs and he just gets like
wrapped up in his delusions so he starts
getting back into this whole my blood
his powder I really needed to like drink
blood so he starts like catching and
killing little animals he would either
eat them raw or he would take their
organs out and put them in a blender
with soda and blend the
all concoction together and drink it
like a [ __ ] smoothie yeah now this is
a sign of [ __ ] insanity okay
naughty no you don't say not even serial
killers did this stupid schmuck
serial killer would know that that
wouldn't work this guy here is not is
just this is schizophrenia this is he's
trying to trying to absorb their
nutrients to keep his [ __ ] yeah
organs together you know he's telling
like bunnies and kitties and [ __ ] yeah
is like body dysmorphia and putting
their like livers and [ __ ] in the
blender yeah and drinketh coke or RC
coal or whatever his preferred so it was
I'm not really sure and you just let him
a California in those days I'll tell you
what it was it was a white rock oh yeah
okay white rock soda yeah I loved it had
a little [ __ ] we didn't have it here
but I've heard of it
my little pixie with [ __ ] yeah yeah
wings drinking out of the water it's
famous yeah yeah yeah like what flavor
was the main was it just caller no the
main flavor was kind of like a 7up oh
that was like well that's the one I
remembered mostly but then they had root
beer I think and they had like grape and
they had a cola
and they had like a ginger ale okay they
had everything yeah I don't think we had
a member here on the East Coast at least
not in Florida but I'm allergic
California and I've seen the UM the
labels cuz like I said I think that
labels are fairly famous yeah and it
came in glass bottles in the caucuses
the quality was good and I just I
remembered as a child in California we
just [ __ ] loved it and it wasn't
expensive it was about kind of like in
the in in in the Michigan area area they
have a go yeah okay which is like a
local yeah call a soft drink although
they sell that pretty much everywhere
they sell everywhere now but back on
them but in California in the 70s the
local soda was [ __ ] white rock yeah I
loved it it was good yeah it was like
the most the most popular flavor that I
remember was like a lemon-lime which
would have been like a like a 7 I'm like
a semi uppers right yeah ok yeah I was
partial to New York seltzer
the black cherry flavor so in August of
1977 the Nevada police find Richard
chase one night hanging out in the Lake
Tahoe area he is completely naked
sitting on a rock like you do completely
covered with blood they also found his
truck that he had driven there like a
pickup truck and in the back of the
pickup truck was a bucket and it had a
liver in it so this looks kind of bad
yeah yeah so the cops arrested him now
initially Richard chase said that the
blood was his and that it had quote
seeped out of him right however later on
they determined that both the blood and
the liver belonged to a cow yeah so
since that's not illegal yeah uh they
let him go now at this point like I said
he was living alone he was apparently
doing a lot of drugs drinking whatever
when he was alone in doing all this
stuff it seemed to like exacerbate his
mental illness and this seems to be one
of the final things that kind of pushed
him into serial killer mode so it's a
few days after Christmas of 1977
apparently Richard Chase was very angry
that his mother had not allowed him to
come home for Christmas because
apparently she you know didn't want him
in the house understandably dirty didn't
want him enough yeah so he was very
lonely he was very frustrated so he
decided to take it out on just random
members of the public now the first
victim of Richard chase was Ambrose
Griffin who was a 51 year old man he was
just out in his driveway helping his
wife bring in groceries from the car and
Richard chase essentially just did a
drive-by he just drove by pulled out a
22 caliber pistol and shot the guy in
the chest just when I was telling you
about that 22 yeah yeah it was just like
a random he just made a random and it's
like no reason he's [ __ ] crazy yeah
so a little less than a month later
January 23rd 1978
um Richard chase busts into the home
well he didn't even bust in the door was
unlocked he just walked into the home of
a woman named Teresa Wallen who was
pregnant her front door was unlocked he
would later say that he felt that the
people that he killed deserved it
because their doors were not locked yeah
it was like an invitation right him like
that's how it's like an invitation for
the vampire to come in to come in yeah
it's kind of like that old trope but I
had to invite the vampire in and then
they can do whatever you want yeah it's
like this girl we're talking about
feeling that just gum we're talking
about for you gun nuts that out there I
think it's like the with the Ruger Mark
3 the one that looked like the Luger it
didn't even have the heavy barrel had
the tapered barrel I saw pictures of it
you know I'm talking about glad Boone it
was blued yeah yeah so he walks into
this pregnant woman's house shoots her
three times that 22 yeah then stabbed
her with a butcher knife then cut out
her organs yeah and drank her blood
allegedly using a yogurt container cup
to scoop of the blood up got that [ __ ]
out of the garbage can classy
[ __ ] with that I guess like
Dennis he is like not commented about oh
you have to understand that you know
he's [ __ ] crazy you just have to like
use what you find on the scene didn't
you do that too though Jenny yeah there
stands up and his motives are totally
inappropriate okay blood is has no
significance
we know that it's it's the [ __ ] and he
doesn't know anything about that Jenny
he doesn't really know anything about
okay he's just trying to drink blood and
well this is your yeah he's wasting it
he's just wasting it he's always yeah
the serial killer angle yeah chase is
[ __ ] crazy all right yeah clearly he's
and he is he doesn't he just wants the
blood he shot her up and then he went
into the [ __ ] little wastebasket that
she had in her in her kitchen yeah and
he found a [ __ ] empty yogurty yeah
yeah and he put that inside of her
abdomen was scooping up yeah I could get
out of out of her abdomen because he cut
a slice through her abdomen to get down
into her and he's trying to get some
blood out of her that way and they found
it they found little blood rings the
cops did where he was setting that cut
down in between drinks you know and see
it's little details like yeah he wasn't
he didn't couldn't have gotten too much
because you know there's not a lot of
blood down the abdomen it's all inside
of person's veins yeah and you need a
beating heart to get it out of the veins
so he doesn't really know what he's
doing you know I mean do you want to
drain a person of a blood they better be
alive so they can pump the [ __ ] blood
out whatever you need a pump to pump it
out it's interestingly like this was the
1970s so they hadn't really like
codified a lot of the you know serial
killer archetypes I guess you know would
be the word for it like the profiling a
why not yeah
but nowadays we would call this a
disorganized yeah a disorganized killer
because clearly he just had he just
wanted the blood he didn't really care
about what kind of mess he made he
didn't really care about I mean he was
basically just walking or random people
says he was in casing the joint he
wasn't doing anything like that he was
just like looking for an unlock card he
just wanted blood that's it yeah and he
was walking around in damn jeans and a
big old [ __ ] some rule a secondhand
Vietnam army jacket OD green with this
pistol [ __ ] shoveling his damn [ __ ]
well in his waistband he's he stick it
out like a sore thumb we're not talking
about a criminal mastermind yeah an
idiot like I said he wasn't no and he
was walking up to people's back doors
that's how he got in and if I remember
this is years ago he walked up to her
back door and got in well he just was
trying doors until yeah it was unlocked
and but he wasn't going through the fry
he was going to the back yeah which is
if you look at you you can just google
any random place around Long Beach
California and see how these cows how
these houses are situated you got to
walk down the street go into their
driveway get behind open a gate usually
get behind the house yeah and [ __ ]
walk up another set of stairs and get in
the back you know look like Bela
Lugosi's house out of the old man
yeah and the old man you know if you
they don't know what I'm talking about
Jenny please everyone seemed Blaine yeah
it's plane I'm from outer space plan 9
from outer space is like some shipment
from that and he's just walk up the
steps and walking in a damn house and
after he did that you know the baby was
in the [ __ ] care baby well this was
the next case it's in the nest case ok I
mean this woman was alright
later on he gets another woman she's got
a baby yeah he drinks it talk about that
yeah I'm getting that
yes he's in the babies to this actually
well like I said he was indiscriminate
he's good he's just looking for blood
this this actually only happened like
four days after he killed the pregnant
woman mhm so January 27th 1978 so he
goes to the house of Evelyn
merav I guess I'm pronouncing that right
her door was unlocked now she was in the
house she also had a six-year-old son
named Jason
she had a 22 month old son or nephew
rather named David Ferreira and also a
friend there whose name was Dan Meredith
now chase just walks in the door which
was unlocked
he shot Dan Meredith in the hallway he
just shot him in the head and then stole
his car keys now also so Evelyn and
Jason the six year old were found in
Evelyn's bedroom little boy had been
shot twice in the head
yeah Evelyn had been killed and
partially eaten her stomach was cut open
several organs were missing
he had also apparently attempted to
remove one of her eyes but had not been
successful
he had also sodomized her corpse yeah
now the baby David who was 22 months old
was missing Evelyn had been babysitting
him it was her got to you now the child
was not found for several months they
looked for him for several months hoping
that he was still alive however not if
I'm in a car
they found him behind a church and he
had been decapitated yeah and he was a
baby from a decapitated a baby yeah if I
remember correctly he was in a cardboard
box had been in a car box for a long
time yeah yeah so now lace behold I
don't hold this [ __ ] fully
response well because he was literally
crazed insane right yeah now it's kind
of different from from your average
serial killer
your average serial killer does not have
schizophrenia they know what's real
the average serial killers doing this
[ __ ] for [ __ ] basically for sexual
motives yeah you know this guy nah not
really
he's he doesn't know what's real he
thinks he's a [ __ ] vampire obviously
like I said he really does seem to
believe yeah yeah um he's gonna die if
he doesn't do this which like I said it
doesn't excuse it but no he's going
crazy he can't help it he's gonna be
locked up he can't help it no but he
shouldn't be allowed to run around loose
obviously he's not innocent right so
what ended up happening was that they
identified Richard Chase as the
perpetrator because he had left
fingerprints in the blood at this
particular crime scene so they were able
to track him back to his apartment they
searched his apartment and they found
that all the utensils in his apartment
were stained with blood and also in his
refrigerator they found human brains so
that's a little incriminating so he got
arrested yeah now his trial began in
January of 1979 and lasted five months
the defense tried to argue that he
shouldn't get the death penalty because
he was insane so he was not guilty by
reason of insanity however the jury
didn't really didn't get on board with
that so he was actually found guilty of
six counts of murder and sentenced to
death in the gas chamber now apparently
when he was in prison the other inmates
were terrified of him
and apparently often encouraged him to
kill himself and eventually he took them
up on it so what he did was they gave
him anti-anxiety medication for all of
the various psychiatric disorders that
he had so he kept stockpiling them until
he had enough that he thought what
overdosed like that would kill him so he
ended up taking them and they found him
dead in his jail cell and the day after
Christmas of 1980
so Richard chase yeah
21 disturbed [ __ ] it's funny
that they were afraid of him in prison
because he didn't weigh anything we're
talking about oh yeah but a hundred
forty pounds psychosis counts for a lot
and that's what I mean because how many
people would like take the organs out of
like a little kitty or a bunny rabbit
and put it in a [ __ ] blender with
soda and drink it or or decapitate a
baby yeah like not you know what I mean
it's like there's some bad [ __ ]
in prison yeah but there's a line man
there's like that he was I mean he was
mentally ill though I mean that's what I
mean so you never knew exactly what he
was gonna do so I'd be [ __ ] scared of
his ass too he didn't really have the
physical power to do anything though I
mean the [ __ ] that he did was because he
had a gun I mean he'd shoot them before
he did all this mostly he was and then
ether I saw photographs of him you know
in his he's a very scrawny fella this is
this dude is not a fiscal threat he's uh
with the 22 then you know especially
with stealth he's just walking up on the
unannounced I mean you know usually
let's say let's say you're a criminal
okay okay you're in the criminal game
alright and you're doing [ __ ] alright
and the organization you work for
decides that you got to go you know
they're coming
you can [ __ ] Kanna prepare yourself
for the attack that's not really the
deal of a chase with chases victims have
no idea anything was going on they'd be
in there making oatmeal
I mean just walk use it maybe even
oatmeal for the baby and they're just
skinny weird
pah-pah-pah don't shoot we just shoot
you in the legs are eating your organ
yeah what the [ __ ] the [ __ ] thinks
that's gonna happen and a 22 pistols not
a combat pistol it's a glorified [ __ ]
BB gun it's a little pop gun yeah no but
enough hits in the right spot will
[ __ ] kill you
well yeah that's what yeah and so will
the [ __ ] air rifle or anything else
but you know it's just but so will fists
and so will hammers and so we'll be the
deadliest [ __ ] thing on the [ __ ]
planet in the United States actually is
a [ __ ] baseball bat a baseball bat
will [ __ ] knock
you don't need sound suppression you
don't anything like that it's just
blunt-force trauma
well there's no really like about horror
movies every time I see like a woman in
a horror movie and she pulls the
baseball bat out from out of the bed
that's about the best thing that chick
knows knows the score yeah that knows
this cuz she does yeah cuz a baseball
bat even to an elbow or a shoulder or a
knee that's a game-changer blunt-force
trauma
oh yeah yeah do you know what I mean
yeah it's a that seems like the but and
honestly it's this is very instructive
that the single time in my life so far
that I experienced night terrors like
where I woke up and thought I was you
know that I was dreaming but I thought
it was awake was I dreamed this is when
I lived by myself in that apartment and
I woke up and the dude that was standing
in my bedroom door had a baseball bat
yeah so that's a bad weapon I know he's
not like to be beaten today when I was
at school like to the fencing you know I
can fence I don't know if you even know
that no you never told me that now I can
fence with a foil but a foil doesn't
have good stopping power it's just
penetration all right
I wouldn't even pick up a katana really
if I want although you couldn't like
whip somebody's armored head off it is a
good dissector now I have to [ __ ]
practice with a good I'm going with
Michonne on that like it was a zombie
apocalypse I would want a katana
when it comes to household implements if
I couldn't have a bat
from the things that I've held in my
hands when it comes to [ __ ] combat or
self defense from [ __ ] just things
you can find around a house the best
weapon I've been able to find in my own
house really would be a rubber body of
Auto Body mallet that's what I would
want a rubber mallet that's what I would
want it's light it hits hard it will not
stick inside of a stout of an opponent
inside of a wound yet and it hits hard
that's why I mean I think rubber mallet
I agree with you on that
yeah not even the [ __ ] metal ones
yeah not so good especially going blind
no because that'll stick and then your
mouth is white
well blow to anywhere in the head or any
anywhere on the skeleton is it's it you
can tell that that's enough for the dick
or the Dickie rubber mallet yeah I mean
you gotta swing you're right
farewell I didn't have a gun or a bat it
would be a rubber [ __ ] body [ __ ]
bodywork mallet I would agree with you
hammer and [ __ ] hammer in and out
[ __ ] body pound and zombie apocalypse
I'll have a katana in one hand and a
rubber mallet in the end yeah cuz guns
ran out of bullets right yeah you gotta
find ammo it's not practical yeah katana
never runs out of bullets
yeah rubber mallet never runs out of
yeah never runs out of all right also
the nice thing about the katana like I
said is that you can like swing it and
you can behead like a bunch of people at
one time
tamo has a long I like that that's what
I mean hey now I reach and if it's sharp
it can go through limbs yeah I may not
have stopping power but it has
penetration right so you can remove and
a thing it's very practical in that type
in a melee type driveway [ __ ] now the
thing is is it's big it's long if you're
in a confined area I'd wrote a sure take
that rubber body well that would be in
the other rubber band you could switch
out like doing around which said you
walking dead you had Tyrone was named
with Tyrone
he had that [ __ ] hammer yeah was his
name Tyrone I think it was a people it
might have been yeah yeah but rubber
mallet would have been
better yeah well especially if you're
going for like head kills yeah well it
won't go through the skull yeah
it'll bounce off the skull but that's
still a [ __ ] heavy [ __ ] blow yeah
bonk someone gets stuck in there and
it's light you can swing it fast well
and once the zombies on the ground you
can just like step on their head or
whatever because they're their skulls
are kind of like we do business people
you know so you know yeah but [ __ ] chase
that's the story to chase like I said he
he is a serial killer but he was kind of
a unique serial killer because of his
mental part because like I said clearly
he had some yeah Rast ik I don't hold
him a hundred percent responsible
because he had organic problems with his
[ __ ] brain human yeah which word
[ __ ] I parrot from a very early
age so schizophrenia like I said is he
completely responsible no um does that
excuse it no no it also does an excuse
and actually just because you have it I
mean I'm kind of the of the of the
[ __ ] opinion that a Mad Dog kind of
has to be put down
life imprisonment or in a mental
institution actually might be inhumane
for a crazy [ __ ] like him and
execution might actually be more humane
you can't let him go
well obviously is too dangerous yeah so
maybe ending his existence in a humane
fashion might be better well and you
know they just suffer if they stay alive
yeah he'd be up in there all my [ __ ]
organs are disintegrating you know
that's what I mean it's like that and
that's like a really um it's like a
really like horrible but also kind of
interesting conundrum to me it's like
what is the point where you were so
mentally ill that it's almost like make
making you suffer more like to stay
alive yeah because like you said if he
was imprisoned he couldn't get blood he
couldn't write like what he thought he
needed then he was probably like
freaking out and like suffering the
whole time because he really did believe
right so it's like it promised me better
they just
well in a way um maybe he thought that
too because he took himself out yeah I
mean well he yeah he's probably escaped
in his own mental anguish that's what
I'm saying
no Sam's like I said I get that because
I've like I you know I've heard stories
of like people that have schizophrenia
stuff like that and it sounds [ __ ]
terrifying and I never [ __ ] want that
so it's like I could understand if
somebody had that and they like they
just couldn't live a normal life they
couldn't like they really did think that
that was happening it's like in a moment
of clarity they would probably think you
know what it's just like I'm just I
can't I gotta check out yeah well you
know normally with a serial killer the
motive is actually just rape well yeah
and that's not the case with chase chase
the [ __ ] motive is to stay alive
because he thinks he's disintegrated
yeah and it's like that doesn't excuse
that no killed like a [ __ ] baby and
you know the pregnant woman the way you
do it's just the way you look at him on
the [ __ ] the way you deal with a
[ __ ] is different when that's
the situation yeah euthanasia actually
would have been I think I kind of
because he had a bunch of [ __ ]
organic problems in his and I don't
think that they could have helped them
no no I don't think because like it and
we've talked about this before I think
most people can be helped but there are
a small percentage that I don't think
can be I think their I think their
problems are just two issues too
deep-set you just can't do anything
about it so anyway some people were not
born right right now I'm really mad it's
rare but I think it does happen cuz like
I said I you know and I've mentioned
this before I think babies are not all
the same I think that there does have to
be usually there has to be like an
interaction between you know your
genetic component and your you know your
upbringing component and like I said I
think some people that were genetically
pretty you know how pretty election for
that like if they're raised okay and
they turn out okay he had a normal
upbringing he did and although I think
that probably was I don't really think
there would be any helping him and
that's you know it's sad but you know
it's sadder for his victims honestly
because they didn't do
you deserve that they were just hanging
out in their houses like a natural
disaster that it is it is it's exactly
like that it's just like a [ __ ]
sinkhole opening up under oath your
house so you'll be sitting up in the
[ __ ] house and all of a sudden boom
when we fall ten stories down into the
[ __ ] it's light of their guts of the
earth because the [ __ ] sinkhole
opened yeah and who we gonna sue
somebody we're gonna cash blame just a
natural disaster where there are human
natural disasters yeah you know chase is
kind of one of those he is kind of
that's that's actually a good analogy
because I don't think that he doesn't
have the same motivations as other
serial killers who I think they knew
what they were doing this wrong but they
just got off on it saying watch the
river he really didn't seem to have that
he really was so delusional yeah that he
thought I have to do this or all died um
so like you said it's more like I don't
really sympathize with him exactly but I
do feel like he was maybe just yes he
just had to be euthanized yeah which
like I said he did end up doing yet in
the end so I guess so that was our show
on Vampire Killers episode her in 66
hope you guys enjoyed it next week is
our Halloween special yeah are you
really
I was I was planning to but we'll see
I'm aware of some I haven't decided I
have a couple of ideas yeah but I don't
know what am i yes I have to go go
through my last time I was singing for
that one probably okay we'll see how it
goes we have no idea we have no plan but
yeah we'll read all you guys so all of
you guys that have sent stories I'll
read all those and we'll do some other
[ __ ] on there we'll have some fun as we
usually do or probably get drunker than
usual so it might be super fun but you
know does Denis have anything to add
go ahead and wrap it up Jimmy okay well
thank you do that alright so I hope you
guys enjoyed episode 166 remember if you
liked the show like share subscribe and
all your social media if you'd like to
financially support [ __ ] and get our
patreon page or you get our blog 13
o'clock podcast at wordpress.com there's
a link in the sidebar to a PayPal
account if you'd like to give it one
time donation and be much appreciated
and that will do it for this episode we
will see you next time bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]